[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
from
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone i'm lucy from gamespot i'm
joined by timor
and michael hi hi hello hey
and welcome to day one of gamesbot's
play for all event so before we get into
what play for all is and speak more to
you know the reveals and stuff coming up
over the next six weeks
we wanted to take a moment to discuss
the awful things that have been
happening
um recently and we want to kind of get
this stream off
on the foot that we support black lives
matter
we absolutely condone and condemn any
kind of racism
uh across the world and what we've been
seeing over the last weekend has been
just awful and we want to do what we can
to help yeah unequivocally
gamespot supports black lives matter
and everything that it fights for
and in our position of we are in
opposition of the systematic racism that
black people face
every single day day in day out we stand
alongside our brothers and sisters and
condemn every form of discrimination
and every act of violence in the black
community
we as gamespot are
we have a responsibility to use our
voice within gaming
to draw focus to the injustices that are
happening
and we want to do that as much as
possible
from this point on going forward
originally we talked about play for all
as being
for a covet 19 relief effort to raise
money for
frontline healthcare workers all over
the world
but in light of the senseless murder of
george floyd
and the events that have followed we
can't in good faith
act to support one cause while another
desperate struggle happens
like you guys you know our heart breaks
for george floyd and his family
and our blood boils when we see these
daily injustices that black people face
the community as a large our friends our
family our colleagues
every single person and i think
as a team we came together and we
decided we'd not decided we
knew that our souls were aching to do
something to try and stand up and do
something
um to do it for george floyd to do it
for
the many other people brianna taylor you
know tony mitchell eric garner
michael brown tamira s there's so many
names that
we can and can't name there's so many
it's impossible but for everyone that
has suffered
and for the people that might suffer
again and will suffer
that if we don't support them we want to
do something
and that's what this was built on
playful was built on bringing a
community together and leveraging our
passion
and the solidarity we have as a
community in gaming to benefit those in
needs
and right now black people are in need
more than most they are the most
affected by covert 19
and now the daily injustices that they
face are
ever more apparent so we want to use
that the opportunity
right now and the voice we have and our
platform to raise money and awareness
for black lives matter
as well as direct relief
yeah so you'll notice on the screen
right now we have two uh urls
one goes to the black lives matter
donate page and one goes to our tiltify
for covered relief um please give
generously they're both incredible
causes but we
we knew we had to do something yeah and
it's
yeah michael um
i'm i'm happy that gamespot has been
able to move so quickly
with this thing with because we put a
lot of time and effort
to make play for all happen and so for
for us to make the move so fast um i'm
happy that i can be a part of that
but i think this moment uh requires us
to ask a lot of tough questions to
ourselves
all right um you know if if
you are if you look at this
and then you feel some sort of hesitancy
uh about us supporting black lives
matter what i ask
i'm i'm asking you to stop for a moment
ask yourself why that is and then do
some research
all right because um
there are things happening like we see
it
on the news we see people with their
with their takes on on the matter
but the root of the problem is the
injustices that black people face
and we need to acknowledge that all
right and
you know these times are tough for a lot
of people
you know especially financially but the
least we can do
is offer our financial support and our
actual support
in our hearts for a movement like this
so that's why we're asking you
to support black lives matter an
organized movement
for black people but another thing to
keep in mind
is that no justice no peace the reason
why you hear these chants
is because there are injustices every
day
not just the things that you see on
camera all right
we've we're seeing a lot of brutal
things happening
caught on camera so imagine the things
that happen
off camera all right and that have been
happening for years
and years and years and i say that to
to contextualize why we are we are
asking you
to support why we are supporting black
lives matter
and in supporting them is a fight
against police brutality
you know uh i think a lot of the
conversations
that we have is centers around that
when black people
receive when when they get their justice
everyone does and i think this is a lot
of what
you hear in response to you know
all lives won't matter until black lives
matter
so what we need to do is support black
lives matter
and that's what we're doing here we're
trying our best to
do that and um like these are
conversations that we're
going to have not just now but
throughout the rest
of our time until there is
actual justice so uh
yeah i think that it's uh we
i i'm i'm happy that all of you out
there can join us
and i hope that you can support us and
like i said
if you are in any way confused if you're
if you're not sure what how to feel or
think
stop yourself ask yourself questions and
do the research all right
um that's the least that's the least i
can ask you to do
uh and then so with that you know we we
play video games
uh for enjoyment right we have fun uh
and you know this is how we relieve
ourselves with the stresses of the day
or we dive into deep worlds and it's
very exciting time for
like during this time we usually expect
e3 which is why we're kind of doing this
but as gamespot if we're going to
put the time and effort to ask for
donations
ask for support in some sort of way this
is
what we need to be doing all right so
i hope all of you can join us in doing
so
it's yeah it's also important to know
that none of us are black
we truly cannot put into words
the things that people who are go
through on a daily basis
all we can do is look at what we see
and hope that we can guide people to
helping in some regards again we'll say
none of us are black we do not have even
the smallest inclination
of what it is like to face that but what
we can do
and what we can pledge gamespot to doing
is
using the platform we have within gaming
a big one
a loud voice within gaming to try and
push people
to the right places to learn to educate
to support
and that's what we want to do and right
now it is so difficult
to talk about video games and doing so
playing them feels at odds with
everything happening around the world
and we
we sat down as a not as a website a team
of you know people who write and work in
website we
sat down as people and we talked about
how can we do this
how can we talk about video games while
all this is happening
and the answer is there really isn't an
easy way to do it
it's close to impossible it doesn't feel
right but what we can do
is if we are going to do this let's use
the voice game spot has to push people
to the right places
let's try and amplify the right voices
that can help guide
and that can help educate and that can
help
raise money to support the black lives
matter movement
and then on top of that to support you
know
the the ongoing efforts to
end this and injustice that are
happening every day
to address the systemic racism within
our society and we hope that you
know that our decision to continue
talking about games to continue
playing games it's not one that we have
done lightly we don't 100
feel great about doing this but at the
same time
it would be worse if we just shut it all
down because
no it wouldn't be worse it would be a
missed opportunity
for us not to take the platform we have
and put it to a good use
we could in some small way
provide some small amount of monetary
support we could help someone
click a link that teaches them and
changes their thinking on this
and ultimately that's what we want to do
we want to make some sort of difference
and we want to try and give you the
opportunity to do the same
and you can do that by donating
using the link that we've got on screen
but you can just go
anywhere and find alternative ways to do
it there is a george floyd
gofundme the minnesota
freedomfund.com.org
donate you can go there there are you
know
change.org petitions you can
find resources readily to help
you focus your efforts and make some
sort of difference
and ultimately that's what all we want
to do right now
the gaming is a part of it the things
that we'll do is a part of it
but it's also a way for us to channel
our passions
to channel the community that we have
into something that could help
in some small way
yeah i mean
like you said none of us are black but
we want
to use our platform and we want to help
in
every in all way that we can like we
can't keep
like this can't just go on and we have
to do something and so
we implore you please check the links
below
please donate to black lives matter if
you can if you're unable to right now
they have a ton of really informative
links that you can go and educate
yourself on the course
because right you don't have to be
an over racist to be racist like it's so
many levels
of the way the people are oppressed
through tons of different means
psychologically through jobs
through society like we
all need to be educating ourselves and
helping break
like break these patterns and put an end
to racism and help people
as we can so that's why we implore you
please check the links below
um it's really difficult to like
segue from this because this is and i'm
not trying to but i'm like
what we'll be doing in the coming weeks
you know we're going to be putting on a
load of charity fundraising things we're
going to be doing streams daily
and we would love you to tune in and
be a part of the conversation and donate
money um
so i guess yeah yeah if you can donate
please do
if you can't amplify the people
the voices in the community that are
doing their best
to try and change this this
sad state of affairs that everyone is in
you
try and have some empathy for the black
communities
that and the black people that go
unheard daily
um we will do our best to
give you charity streams and and forms
of entertainment
that uplift but at the same time please
remember there are people out there who
don't have the option to tune in
watching a video game stream isn't going
to help them what will help them
is you donating some money or sharing a
link
and making it more visible what's
what they suffer on a daily basis it
might not help immediately
but it could help in the long term and
it's crucial that we do that it's
crucial that everyone
takes this opportunity to do that
yeah um if i could add just a few other
things about
you know we obviously we want to raise
money
for blm but it's also your duty
to continue the conversations further to
internalize
the things that you learn through this
uh through reading about black lives
matter through
following the news and i think that
you know understanding what systemic
racism
is you know it's not just
people like lucy said it's not just
people being outwardly racist
there are systems in place that are
inherently
biased against black people such as
the travesties that we see with abusive
power
in law enforcement those are things that
blm
are fighting against they're actively
putting
time and effort their hearts and souls
into
fighting against and changing because
you know financial support
is is core to letting
us make a difference so that's why these
donations matter
and black lives matter being an
organized movement
that's that's important to to support
but also you need to take these
conversations to the people that you
know
all right and if if you if you
understand this
and if you um if you understand this
conversation
then i encourage you to carry it on in
your everyday life
you know uh and as tomorrow said like
tamora and i
are non-black people of color
so it's important for us to
for us to be like
our our people have faced injustices too
and i think we need to have a
conversation with our with our
communities with my family for me i need
to talk to
asian americans to filipinos about how
this is our fight too all right um
we need to come out in support of black
people
and i think that we like
i mean obviously white people need to
come out and yeah
to do their part and acknowledge that
they're that they have privilege all
right that
like that is a very big conversation
and it's hard for a lot of people to
recognize that privilege
but it's so important and you need to be
having those difficult conversations not
only with yourself
with your immediate friends and family
and challenge
the perception of your place in the
world and other people's place in the
world
and a lot of the literature that's been
shared around right now that's super
important to read is kind of recognizing
that privilege
and i'm a white person i know that i
have privilege and
i think speaking for myself i've been
quiet on this for too long and that's
not being
an ally that's not helping anyone so
on a personal level and you know working
at gamespot we're
we're doing something we're using the
platform that we've been given
to hopefully help out it's it's the same
like michael said
i'm we're not we're not black people we
are people of color
we i again as i said before i cannot
begin to
understand the injustices that black
people face
but it now more than ever it's apparent
that everyone's voices need to be louder
if not for ourselves you have black
friends you have
black colleagues you live in communities
with black people
and you know and love them you
you owe it it's your responsibility to
stand up
to create the world that that they can
live in
that you can live in that your family
can live in and their family can live in
together
and the only way you can do that is by
standing up
for someone else to outstretching a hand
to someone else
in need and black people are in need
right now and we talked about
this entire time playful was designed
and created and
put together from the gamespot stuff
with love and and and genuine
want desire to do something to help
people
who are suffering through culvert 19
healthcare workers
black people are disproportionately
affected by covert 19
and it might be tricky for you to you
know try and
create distinctions and that kind of
stuff but it doesn't need to be these
the communities that are facing social
injustice and systemic racism
are also being hit hard by covid please
open your hearts and open your minds to
to both
you know let black lives matter guide
you
and let love guide the way you behave
now
yeah so we just wanted to start uh
playful with that message
and we hope that it resonates with you
and
that you'll consider visiting the links
below they're on screen right now
donate money if you can and if you can't
please amplify
black voices please spread the word as
to what black lives matter are doing
and help out in other ways um
yeah so that's we're gonna work yeah
we're gonna we're gonna continue
we have programming you know for the
next few weeks
ready and we have a lot of fun things
coming and
we want you to keep in mind that when
you're doing this like
please donate there's people who don't
have the opportunity to enjoy what we
have in the same way that you can
please reach out following this we're
gonna have an interview with
tim sweeney and kim library of epic
games
and we're going to do our best this was
that interview was re
created i conducted it before before
the events of the weekend it was
happened last week and
there's no mention of it in there it's
because
that that happened you know last week
and i if i had
if i could i would have done said it
there but i have an intro in it and it
doesn't
and i've i feel weird about it not
having that but
we'll do our best to at every
opportunity
before before pre-shows and you know
during streams to mention black lives
matter
mention the covet uh relief efforts as
much as possible
um so when you are watching this whether
we're saying or not please do your best
to spread the word
um all this money is going to charity
we're not taking anything out of this we
this doesn't benefit gamespot um
monetarily anyway all of it is going
to charitable causes please do what you
can
so yeah in this week alone you know
we've got
a lot of pears we have uh min max
and so then we'll have folks from easy
allies and um
game ranks jesus is doing a bloodborne
speed run
so these are just some of the things
this is just week one that we've planned
um so there's plenty of different things
that we hope you'll enjoy and that you
can
drop in on you know if you know
if a let's play isn't your thing then
maybe you'll join in for a speed run
or something so we tried to cater for as
many
tastes as possible we really hope you'll
join and
donate some money yeah so after this
we're going to have the tim sweeney
interview
it's let's be honest it's on real engine
it's there's a lot to get out of it but
um it's also kind of like there's
nothing new to talk about so we
elaborated on some of the things that
tim and kim talked about with the
interview during um
the game fest off with jeff keeley
um i asked them about the
wendy's versus uh popeye's debate that
was happening
afterwards um we tried to get fun with
it
i hope you tune in and watch it is
slightly more light-hearted than you
might expect from the ceo and cto of
epic games um and then after that we're
going to be joining
a few folks from the giant bomb team
abby
ben and vinnie um
for a board game stream uh
and we'll be doing that for a couple of
hours and we're gonna see what happens
there it'll be myself and
michael hyam joining from the gamespot
side
um and then that'll be that's right
that's the monday of play for all pretty
much
um uh and then you know for the rest of
the week you'll see
that as lucy said mid max gaming trivia
it's going to be
fun and hilarious we've been talking to
ben about it and listening to his idea
and it sounds like
yeah yeah 1x we did tell them we told
them
ben hansen if you're watching this we're
sorry we told them uh
and then after that um we have uh alana
pierce coming in
um i'm not actually sure what alana's
doing but i'm sure whatever it is it's
gonna be amazing
i think amanda and i are gonna play some
games i was chatting to her about it on
the weekend but
kalana um actually over the weekend
herself did an amazing stream yes i
think she raised like over fifty
thousand dollars for black lives matter
she got like jacksepticeye in
uh so that's great so we hope that uh
yeah we'll get money donated on our
streams too um
actually i think we're going to play
some chill games
um um
yeah and then we have like i said
earlier um jesus
uh i'll get them from june 4th the big
one
um sony's ps5 event which um
uh falls on top of another awesome
charity event that we had planned but
um we're going to find a new spot for
that but it's going to be awesome um
it will involve abu bakr saleem and alex
wilton reagan who you might know as
bayek and aya from assassin's creed
origins
um we're going to find a new spot for
those those folks because it's really
cool
what they want to do but that day will
be devoted to
playstation coverage um we're gonna have
a pre-show
pro show as well um we'll have analysis
of everything that's shown
so you can expect the same kind of
treatment that we would give to e3
content um on that day and then the
friday we're gonna
finish things up with um jesus
hairstyles which if you know anything
about
um speedrunning you'll know he's the
best in the business when it comes to
bloodborne
he's the blood god of bloodborne he's
done many many amazing streams
the thing i love about his streams are
they don't always go to plan
it's not perfect perfect um you know
speedrunning but he always runs with it
he has fun with it
he creates narratives within the
speedrun itself that are fantastic
and bloodborne he loves ladders
um he's got a fantastic beard um
and uh yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be
amazing i'm
gonna be on it um me and jake decker um
are gonna be his peanut gallery
uh trying not to you know ruin his
his flow but we'll be hanging out and
just check
chatting away while he does his thing um
and we hope that you can
tune in for that um again
as we said earlier it's it feels weird
to be playing games and trying to do
this stuff while
you know the world around us is going
through what it is but
we hope that by doing this and
continuing to carry on with these
charity streams and
event coverage that we can amplify the
right voices
and we hope that while you're watching
you take the opportunity to
donate if you can if you can't share
they'll share those voices
um amplify the voices who are able to
you know educate and and tell people
about what's going on
and just keep it in your heart and keep
in your mind that
black lives matter and people need help
out there
uh i wanna i wanna take a little bit of
time to kind of
wrap both um
um understanding uh
black justice and gaming in a way
that i think that you know looking at
what we're doing i think
we can also acknowledge that we
should moving forward or at any time
all the time we should be amplifying
not just people of color but
specifically black voices
uh and in the gaming space there are a
lot of black people
all right you know gaming isn't
gaming touches everyone obviously there
are plenty of black streamers
plenty of black influencers black
journalists out there
and you should all be following them
whether it's on twitter or teaming up
with their work
because again donations are so
appreciated for the movement
but to continue understanding what this
is i think that you also like if you
care about gaming
you should be following these people
i'll just name it there there are so
many
that i can name but just off the top of
the brain um
i'm good friends with khalif adams that
spawn on me blessing adioya junior
uh kind of funny tanya de pass is
an incredible speaker who's at
conventions and
always educating people uh just through
her conversations
and through what she does at conventions
all right uh and it's very important to
listen to black women
all right uh and there are plenty of
them
in the gaming spaces all right and
there's a lot of other folks
uh who are writers um
on staff i think you should pay
attention to jordan remain
who's on our staff and alessandro
fellari who's on her staff greg thomas
is an incredible video producer
for gamespot universe and um
there are a lot of folks out there like
like i said and uh
yeah you seek them out seek them out
follow them because you know they love
gaming too they'll cover gaming
just the way anyone else would but they
will put their voices into it and you
will learn
a broader perspective as it relates to
gaming
and just just quickly kind of funny our
friends there blessing
is heading up a week long of a week of
coverage um
using just having black voices on there
so when we're not streaming or
you know you don't have to pick and
choose it doesn't make a difference to
us if you want to go and watch the kind
of funny stuff please do that
they are doing um fantastic work putting
blessing and
various other you know black voices
front and center to educate us so
please feel free to go there and watch
that stuff too
yeah support and amplify black voices
um and please donate if you can but also
just
educate yourself on what's going on um
and i think yeah we're all
to reiterate we're all appalled by
what's been happening and
we want to do what we can to help so we
hope that you'll join us
on this journey we're going to be
kicking off very soon with the tim
sweeney
interview um don't forget to come back
at the end
tam and michael will be playing video
game well what are you playing it's like
a table top sim
it should be table top simulator i think
it's called murder in hong kong that's
what we tested
um but we'll see what happens vinnie's
vinnie does this
you know how everyone knows how vinnie
is vinnie does well thing so we could
get in there and he's like we're all
playing scrabble now
hey don't knock scrabble on table talks
we did that a couple weeks ago
so yeah nothing else um
but we wanted to say thank you to the
people who've already been donating
thank you for the people who are
you know hopping in the chat and taking
something away from this
um we yeah we felt like it was really
important to start with this message and
it's something we're going to be
carrying on
throughout the entirety of play for all
we're going to be talking about it and
beyond
um so thank you for joining us and um
any closing words from you guys
no black lives matter black lives matter
yep all right um well in that case i
think it's time to go over to the first
big interview of play for all
we've got tim sweeney and tom what was
the other guy's name
kim library kim library from
kim tim and kim that's lovely
uh tim and kim from epic games to talk
about the new unreal engine and the
future of gaming and don't forget
games of giant bomb when we come back
yeah
you're watching day one of game sports
play for all event and it is my great
pleasure to be joined by tim sweeney and
kim library of epic games how's it going
guys
good fantastic um obviously you guys
have
had quite a few weeks you unveiled
unreal engine 5 and talked about the
future of
you know the the engine that kind of
powers much of with the video game
industry
so i think we want to dive in quickly
into the really important stuff and
obviously the most important thing from
your um recent revelation
were tim sweeney um had for some reason
a plasma ball
in the background of his uh interview
tim can you tell us
about the story behind the plasma ball
please sure well this is your world
exclusive um but uh
so we're preparing for a jeff keeley
show and uh
i realized it was going to be filmed and
so uh the the mess that was behind me in
my office needed to be cleaned up so i
was running around cleaning up the
office
i knocked over my diet coke which i
always have
with me and so i had this giant a spill
of diet coke there and we were about to
begin
filming in like 30 seconds so i grabbed
the nearest object which was this uh
it came from spencer's at the mall and
it was covering up the diet coke spill
and nobody nobody was the wiser in fact
this
wild conspiracy theory about what it was
meant to symbolize
for the record does it symbolize
anything about the future of fortnite or
unreal engine 5
no no no i mean you would say that
wouldn't you but so um well but i
the the way the way we approach fortnite
it's the work of an awesome creative
team
i last designed the game myself in 1992.
the other thing that people want to know
is are you
a a a popeyes or a wendy's person
is always excellent sometimes but
sometimes virgin anglers
they're oj is very good too kim can you
watch your what's your
restaurant of choice oh my goodness my
rest no choice but in terms of fast food
uh restaurants uh unfortunately i can't
get it here but it's it will be a little
cheeky nandos
every so often would you fernando's yes
you can't you can't get rid of the brit
in you
cheeky nandos my accent may have mutated
over the last 20 years but i still like
a bit of nandos when i go home
fantastic we're on the cusp of a
generational transition
you've unveiled new technology that will
push gaming forward and various other
mediums
and taking a slightly retrospective look
what has been your key takeaways from
the generation that was what do you
think that we
um as an industry as developers yourself
and people who are behind you know
engines and various other things
to do with gaming what do we do good and
what do you think we could do better
yeah with this generation it we pushed a
lot of things to the limit a lot of
amazing lighting
and rendering technology has emerged
here um we've been able to do
some pretty impressive open world games
with big scenes you know
fortnite with a hundred players and a
massive
multiplayer game and some amount of
dynamic lighting but we've
really run up against a brick wall um in
terms of
achieving absolute photorealism and so
it's been a it's been an
interesting learning process we just
kind of got to the door of a photo
realism but couldn't quite get in
but at the same time this is the console
generation when microsoft and sony and
nintendo all finally came together
and opened up cross-platform play and we
saw gaming emerged as a
a social phenomenon in this generation
you know we're at fortnite and
rocket league now call of duty and lots
of other games are
connecting all the different players
across all the platforms in a single
live game environment with all their
friends and that's been a really great
boon for the industry
i think this generation has some really
great storytelling in video games i
think that the the
you know division between films and
games
as being good storytelling mediums is
sort of it's been whittled away a lot
in this generation and i think this this
phenomenon that
you can go to a virtual world and hang
out with your friends and do cool things
that are different every night is
something that i think that the games
industry can be really really proud of
that
we you know we've made a destination for
people to have entertainment
that isn't you know in in normal
physical spaces and obviously you know
during the situation we're in with that
right now with colby 19
games have brought people together
people across the whole planet can
interact
in ways they would do if they were in
the same space but within a virtual
world
so i think the you know the big
multiplayer social experiences a bit is
probably one of the most exciting parts
of the last generation
for sure i think one of the interesting
things or perhaps something that's being
lost in
translation or it perhaps isn't clear to
people is when you revealed the
engine a lot of it was about triangles
for example and
photorealism but i think what people
might not have as good a grasp on is
like the applicability of unreal engine
beyond photorealism obviously you can
take that engine and
create all kinds of various styles like
can you talk a bit about
how it can be used within gaming not
just for photorealism but how it
empowers a variety of art styles and a
variety of experiences
making a great world environment
characters
is not you know photorealism is it
doesn't have to be part of that
what matters is detail and richness and
believability and plausibility of the
environment you're in so you know the
techniques that we use for photorealism
also apply
you know very very well to completely
stylize the improvements in fact
you know when i used to work in the
movie business i you know i
did a lot of movies with the wachowskis
and we did one movie called speed racer
and speed racer is founded completely on
the principles of photorealistic
rendering
but it's made to look like nothing
you've ever seen before
and i think that you know the the the
cool thing with um
more um believable lighting
richer more detailed geometry means that
people can just believe the place is an
actual
place they could visit it helps the
brain understand where they are
but the you know the other cool side
effect of having a system that
is not only just detail but also has you
know dynamic lighting it means that
environments can be completely dynamic
things can change the cause and effect
can happen in games
you know we all play these big massive
games and you walk past the same but it
doesn't really change you know it's
pretty static most
most gaming walls right now sort of a
built on this
you know builder ink you know build as
detail as thing as you can and it's
quite static
and it can't change over time it's hard
to incorporate user generated content
with this technology it means that
worlds can grow and evolve
can be a completely different thing from
one day to the next and i think that's
going to open
new gameplay mechanisms that we haven't
been able to do in the past so i think
it's a pretty
exciting time for for just experimenting
with totally new ideas
you guys were very effusive about the uh
the capabilities of the playstation 5
and the time following there were a lot
of questions around
what that means for sirius x and
microsoft and
uh can you talk a bit about um the the
dynamic and the relationship between ue5
and xbox series x i know kim earlier you
mentioned that
if we if if we weren't looking at this
fantasy kingdom behind you we would see
both an xbox and a ps4 controller behind
you
do you want to put those conspiracies to
rest
oh yeah sure you know the the nanite and
the lumen technology is built
to run on you know next-generation
consoles and high-end pc xbox series x
playstation 5 and uh
you know at least the highest high-end
nvidia and amd gpus
and support content they can scale down
to you know all over and platforms
we're really closely partnered with sony
on that demo
we literally had been talking to them
for it must have been
three or four or five years about not
just graphics because
obviously we talk about graphics but
also storage architecture and all the
supporting systems that are needed to
build
next generation games um they have vast
amounts of the
visual detail and need to bring in you
know detail
every frame at a very high frame rate
and a very high level of fidelity the
focus of that was on the playstation 5
hardware it was running on
you know we support all the platforms
both uh sony and microsoft first party
developers are using unreal engine um
for projects you've seen some ship
um they're really awesome and more
coming in the future it was just an
awesome the culmination of a really
awesome partnership that had been going
on for a very long time
no no conspiracy then is that what
you're saying no no conspiracy
um yeah we love all of our children
yeah and we have a very close
relationship with many of the microsoft
studios that are
awesome and real engine users and you
know i think i think the next generation
is going to be amazing for all gamers
you know regardless of what platform you
want to choose and orange will run well
on all of them
one of the things that you mentioned a
few times in the interview with jeff
kelly and also
a few times today is the the kind of
relationship with hollywood and cinema
and that kind of stuff can you talk
about what
going beyond just gaming and reaching
into hollywood and other forms of
entertainment and media what does that
mean for you and
how do you think that will benefit james
as a whole for quite a while
the the core tools that we use to make
assets for
games and movies have been pretty
similar there was always been this extra
stage of making normal maps and low
resolution measures
and you know we know that hollywood
over the last 20 years you know i was
part of i worked in the film business
for a decent amount of time making
movies
um you know sort of pioneered computer
graphics and the pursuit of realism so
there was a lot to be learned
from them techniques and you know as we
approach you know peak photorealism for
interactive entertainment
within games um uh we were able to sort
of get ahead
by actually supporting that industry not
in a way that was a diversion
almost everything that we've done that
enables hollywood to make better pixels
is
also being used by game developers you
know better blend shape systems for
faces
better eye shaders better hair we're
seeing all our developers making games
that
require you know digital humors or
digital characters uh to use that stuff
but um what what it's definitely doing
is there's a simple effect that hey the
engine produces better looking pixels
out of the box
but the the really cool thing is that
we're now seeing a crossover
of the way that people think in both
industries yeah
um i think you see you know these great
storytelling games built on our engine
and other engines
are definitely using hollywood tricks to
lens things and frame things and
help um audiences or players understand
better the story that they're trying to
take
you know facial animation technology is
pretty much the same
in both industries now if you if you go
and play red dead redemption
or the horizon zero dawn great facial
animation and it's done
you know it may not be quite to the same
fidelity today on this generation but it
will be on the next generation it's the
same stuff so
the two industries are helping each
other but there's this cool
side effect of you know working on the
mandalorian where um
john favreau is able to use a real-time
engine
to produce the pixels that produce his
final shots
make him start to think about oh well if
we do a dog fight here
should i use gameplay dogfight should i
make some vehicles that i can fly
should we make a weather system and i
think eventually what's going to happen
is that
ips will no longer be these oh it was a
movie it got converted into a game where
it was a game that becomes a movie
i think there'll be this continuum
between the two worlds and i think
that the artists will be crossover i
think that we'll
we'll see when it comes to content
creators for making you know cg assets
whether it's making a car
or making a chair or whatever or a rock
they'll be the same for both industries
and i see we'll see a massive
cross-pollination between these two
worlds
and does that mean that games and movies
will be better
yeah but i think we'll see new types of
entertainment you know look at how we're
blowing the lines in fortnite we have
concerts happening in fortnite where
millions of people take place and i
think entertainment's going to go to
this awesome mutation over the next five
years
that really bless the line that sounds
incredible it also sounds like you guys
are preparing to bring back the the age
of the license game in a new way
i'm very very happy to hear that i'm a
new
batman game that's so based on a movie
or you know well i just think you you
think about like
so imagine i'm not no idea what one has
planned to do with it but
imagine they were making a new um batman
game for for next generation consoles
yeah
we know that's gonna look amazing it's
gonna look pretty much like a high-end
animated movie
with badass video game in action well
wouldn't it be great for fans to go
deeper
and see animated stories in that world
using the same assets and the same
characters
would it be great that then things are
rendered live on your playstation 5 or
your next generation xbox
and they're shareable and modifiable and
the the sky's the limit i think we're
going to see some really crazy
developments over the next
five years tim what's it been like for
you to kind of watch this
evolution because you've been here from
the start and
you know you start off making a game
engine and making games and now you're
sounds like you're trying to change the
way we consume entertainment as a whole
and it's still
it's core anchored on unreal engine that
must be mind-boggling right
it's been an astonishing amount of
progress in the industry over the past
20 years computers are a million times
faster now you know for graphics
processing than they were back then
so it's been really really fantastic to
see it and i think back then
in the very early days of unreal it
became it was becoming obvious that
real-time computer graphics would have
far-reaching effects on
society it would they just have to reach
new levels of quality to get there
it's taken a very long time to build it
up to that point you know it's the point
where you're actually shooting
live shots in the mandalorian both
real-time computer graphics backgrounds
and it can be used by architects and
automotive designers and everybody else
for
photo real versions of their you know
products for for marketing and for
uh product visualization it's funny
because actually back in those early
days it was like 1996
97 when a cd-rom was invented and became
a widespread
thing everybody was out and buying and
talking about and we had this idea of uh
of transmedia and of uh you know movies
and televisions
converging with games to produce new
form of entertainment um and
the result was a bunch of hokey games
that were just like watching a movie and
then clicking and picking a static
choice and
that didn't work um nobody wanted that
but
it's actually finally happening now
right and it just
shows that a lot of these predictions
that were made about the future that
seem to be wrong
um we're just early um and they're
actually happening
at scale now it definitely seems that
way um stepping away into the um
other big thing that you guys have going
for tonight um
massive success story obviously um
what has been your key takeaways from
fortnite's
growth and evolution into what it is now
um
i know tim you said you don't create
fortnite you're not
mr fortnite but obviously you've been a
key part of it
for both of you what do you think has
been those takeaways for you
games aren't just for hardcore gamers
right games are a medium
that everybody can enjoy you know the
fact that fortnite um you know though
it's a battle royale game a pretty
serious game type you have to play
pretty seriously for a huge
range of gamers of all sorts uh hardcore
gamers and casual gamers and
guy gamers and female gamers of all ages
as the guy has
not ever been the fortnight designer but
has been you know one of the technology
advocates uh behind some of the
decisions we've made i
couldn't be happier than to see what all
the different platforms have made
possible
and finally opening up and enable gamers
to connect together
you know one one of the most awesome
parts of it is that you know
you you make a traditional box product
game you make it you work very hard you
probably put it out and then you have
fans
but you don't have this live connection
yeah you know the fans of the game are
there
playing it right now as we speak
millions and millions of people having
fun
being connected to us and us being
connected to them is a pretty incredible
feeling and
also a huge responsibility to make sure
that we do the right thing by gamers and
uh
and uh offer enough options as the game
evolves into all these different things
that
they stay entertained it's it's
interesting it's it's a it's a it's a
little bit
akin to running a core game with the
theme park at the same time it's been a
pretty pretty exciting evolution for us
i'm gonna be honest with you um i
probably write more about fortnite than
i actually play
um and it's something i think about
almost daily because you know the way
that
the the world works in online print and
and that kind of stuff
and i just want to go back to that time
when you guys basically hit reset on it
and
did that thing where you're like the
world is exploding that was like the
first time
in ages that i i knew that i didn't have
to
think about covering fortnite for like
maybe an hour or two
and it was like life-changing it felt
like the world came to a stop and i
think a lot of people
who play fortnite cover for tonight's
dream fauna probably
felt the same way what's it like to know
that you have a game where
when it stops to be functioning it's
almost as if the world has come to a
grinding halt
what's that kind of knowing that you
have that kind of impact
what's that like i think that's the neat
thing about the world the fortnite
creative team is put together it's a
it's a magical place in itself uh it is
as real to people as you know a lot of
the environments where they live in real
life
and it kind of transcends everything
right any game developer is always going
to be an imperfect company
people are always mad at epic for this
feature or that
downtime or you know any other thing
like that but uh but the fortnite world
itself is above it and it's kind of
separate from the
the company and it's as much the product
of the community as uh
of the company it's the it's the players
and the streamers and the fortnight
creative
authors that make it what it is and it's
it's really a constant evolution of the
community playing it finding things
suggesting things in the game evolving
to adapt you know with all the latest
earnings and even though uh
we don't like to really go out we like
the team likes to talk
to the world through the game right we
like to go out and make big statements
about our
you know the creative efforts it's it's
much much more about communicating with
players through the evolution of what
happens in the world
and it's imperfect but it is really
quite a magical thing
it's it's it's very humbling you know
that that moment
it's funny i don't work directly on the
game although a lot of my friends work
on the game
but we all knew that we were going to
shut it off for a period of time and
you know internally there's a lot of you
know oh my god is this the right thing
are we going to
lose our players are they going to be
upset with us and we don't know we're
just you know we're regular human
beings that make video games yeah but
the the lesson there for all developers
is
don't be afraid to do the thing that
feels a little bit crazy and exciting
like don't don't over analyze it like we
just we just did it and we're like well
we'll see
we'll see what happens and it worked and
honestly many of our decisions have been
about
you know just just not being super
conservative
and overthinking things like go with
your gut instincts and
you know if you if your players love
your game even if you make a mistake
they cut
you you can course correct and come back
people shouldn't be afraid to be
experimental and do
new and interesting things and i think
that's one of the most wonderful things
about
being part of epic and having such a
humbling audience that plays our games
it's been an amazing few years yeah i
think whether you play it like it or not
i think
one thing that's not arguable is like
it's it is a fascinating game and it's
constantly trying to upend your
expectations and do something different
so even as someone who is in that moment
was like great i don't have to think
about fortnite for a couple days
the whole thing really did fascinate me
i wasn't writing about it but i had my
eye on it and it wasn't just because i
was waiting for it something to happen
it was because i genuinely was
interested in seeing what was going to
happen next
it's almost like a impressive viewing
experience from the outside as well
it's actually one interesting thing for
just entertainment in general
you know with the with the advent of
streaming and people you know binge
watching and just watching stuff when
they want
that whole live event you know i'm
pretty old so when i was a kid back in
the uk we had four channels
and like three three when i was a little
kid but we won't talk about that
you know that that whole thing of
everybody talking about the same thing
did you see that on tv last night like
we've sort of with these live events in
our game and other games and what
they're doing
doing the same thing you universally
across the planet at the same time again
everybody talking is a really cool cool
part of being a human being and the fact
that we are connected with the internet
and things can spread is really exciting
and i i think i hope that the the
streaming companies realize that like
live stuff
like lifestyle doing something it's a
pretty powerful thing and it really does
get people talking i mean i think the
the impact of it
and fortnite kind of leading charge is
immediately already visible like it's
it's unconfirmed and it's rumors right
now but like there's
talks of you know the next call of duty
being revealed through warzone
and that wouldn't happen unless fortnite
was doing what it did
um and then non-sequitur you've just
reminded me about the first time channel
5 came into existence do you remember
that
no because i think well i might when did
channel 5 open i left in 97 so i i think
it was like on the cusp of me of me
coming moving to america
yeah i think i think it was it would
probably have been after that because i
remember being in the teenager years
and it blew my mind that another channel
could just be created and added to
television
yeah it's amazing ridiculous
i'm not old i'd remember color tv coming
into our house
for the longest time i used to play my
sega mega drive on a black and white tv
and even when color tvs existed and it
was like playing aladdin on in black and
white was both bizarre and
when i play aladdin now i'm like if he
was wrong because it's colored and i'm
like it should be in black and white
tim how you doing there with your uh
diet coke in a popeye's cup still good
yeah it's good to have a plenty
fantastic one of the other key things
that you talked about and
um announced afterwards was the changes
to the epic online service things that
were happening
um you kind of have uh
you're empowering people with more you
know connectivity and networking options
can you talk a bit about that and
what effect do you potentially see it
having on the wider gaming industry
sure you know since 2012 we've been
building this really extensive set of
back-end systems for um for all of our
games to provide
accounts and social features and friends
um we're working on voice
um and other communication features um
all the services need to match make
players together into a cross-platform
game experience and so uh
the epic online service initiative is
aimed at opening up all of that stuff we
built um to all other game developers
for free
it's really especially especially
targeted at the cross-platform problem
because if you look at building a game
and shipping a lot of platforms
there's xbox live there's playstation
network there's the nintendo
online services and then there's steam
and you know other services proprietary
to each publisher
but when you're shipping a
multi-platform game each one is
is still you know locked to only
interoperate with players in the same
device family um and so
by integrating the epic services you can
use the platform services side by side
with multi-platform services and really
connect all of your players
you know when you look at fortnite's
growth there are really two big growth
spurts one began
um when the battle royale mode launched
just had this magical combination of
gameplay that
created a new type of experience but the
other major growth spurt occurred when
we connected all the platforms together
enabled everybody to play with all their
friends everywhere and people would play
together with their friends
spend a lot more time playing the game
together they enjoyed the game more
they spend more money every aspect of
the game
experience becomes better for them and
better for the game developers too
um when you have a complete social
framework like that so opening up to all
developers is a way of jump starting
that and we did it for free too you know
the cost of operating these services is
fairly small um
we're not running we're not offering
free game servers right those are
massively expensive and consumer
engagement of hardware horsepower we're
talking about friends and accounts and
matchmaking and these kind of
asynchronous backend services and so the
cost of operating is low enough that
we're able to offer it to all developers
for free and
we benefit by the growth of the player
network
every time a new gamer comes in and
creates an account and every time they
make new friends in the game that
friends
relationships benefit every game that
uses the services including ours
um and so it's a really great collective
way for the game industry to kind of
approach the next generation of
cross-platform features together epic
and utem
specifically have been big proponents of
cross-platform play and creating a
homogeneous kind of environment for
everyone to
to kind of play together um we've made
some inroads there you know some
companies have been a little more
vocal about being into the idea while
others are a little still they have
some walls around their gardens so to
speak um why do you think it's important
to have this and what would you say to
anyone developer publisher or even
platform holder that might still be
gingerly kind of
approaching it and might still have some
thoughts about trying to maintain these
walled gardens
right now every platform supports a
cross-platform play
and in none of those cases has it been a
special exception made just for fortnite
in every
case sony and microsoft and nintendo
have opened this up as a general program
any developer can participate in there
are always a lot of business forces
shaping all of this
a lot of fear of the unknown
and recognition of you know if we can
connect these devices together then
you know what will happen will will the
internet blow up and will uh
you know players be able to trust
players on other devices
but you know it's worked out remarkably
well and there's been
it's just a just a wonderful community
around fortnite um really
i think the lowest toxic toxicity
community you see in gaming
um as a result of the kind of the style
of the game and the spirit of the
gameplay
we're super happy with where all the
console makers stand they've
solved all the all the challenges and
all the concerns we had in the past and
we've been a little bit vocal about this
right we've had some disagreements
with folks over across platform play but
those are all solved and uh
we have some disagreements with the
mobile uh platforms right now over the
the business practices and i think
that's going to be another frontier that
the whole game industry is going to need
to work together to
push forward over this next generation
you know in the spirit of having open
platforms which uh
all developers can participate and
freely i'm gonna be honest with you guys
i really miss seeing the plasma ball on
the background
kim i i like your background currently
but
earlier you showed me something i am
i've got i've got my awesome plasma ball
in the back is
my game yes that's more like it thank
you tim please plug it in for us
it's just uh it's um there you go that's
the there there it is but uh
i was having a little bit of a plasma um
war with uh
with tim the other the other day so we
uh i upgraded i level now
yeah the problem this thing i put out
puts out so much electromagnetic
interference they'll actually like
force my computer to turn it off or my
well hold on phone might go down don't
don't yeah don't do that
let's see what happens it might work
if you imagine if tim just ends this
interview because he's the sheer force
of power coming
yeah that's more like right
better oh yours looks better just more
real your one looks better but i'm gonna
be honest kim you've got some like
megalomaniac and villain energy going on
with you right now
like just it looks like you're about to
plot world domination
which i guess if if unreal engine 5 goes
the way you want maybe is the case
i'll i'll just go back into my construct
yeah if you don't that's good that's
good that's pretty good
thank you so much for putting both of
you for giving us a bit of that hit of
the plasma ball
i'm very excited yeah it's great i plan
to pull it away and not bring it out
until there's another diet coke spell
[Laughter]
moving on epic game store that's been a
huge initiative for you guys recently um
you wanted it to be a kind of challenger
to the status quo
um when it came to digital delivery and
to be almost kind of a disruptive
element in the industry
has that been the case and how has that
been received by the wider game industry
it was a daunting challenge right this
is challenging an entrenched competitor
in a very well established market is uh
is fraught with peril and if you look at
the the previous stores that launched
some pc
gog and humble both are really awesome
stores um
both of them launched with a lot more
features than the epic game store had
um both of them spent years getting up
to the point of uh having
like half a percent of market share or
one percent of market share and so
we realized early on we needed to take a
a really really bold approach
and a disruptive approach and so free
game program was launched
exclusives were launched and you know a
lot of things that we knew would be uh
be controversial in some ways especially
with the hardcore you know steam gamers
who
bought hundreds of games on steam and
we'll buy all their games on steam
but uh it's worked incredibly well you
know in our first um 15 months we ended
up
up with about 15 market share it's still
growing our usage
rate our monthly active users since that
point when we started announcing those
numbers
have has gone up and more than doubled
um
and so we what we see is a really
healthy robust alternate store ecosystem
growing
and bringing these better economics to
all developers you know the
revenue sharing giving developers 88 of
the revenue instead of um 70 percent
really is aimed at shaking up the
economics and all of the
open platforms and platforms that should
be open and we'd like to bring the store
to uh
ios in the future and we will bring it
to android we think it's a good way to
help the industry forward and
it's another way where you know epic as
a game developer had built up this
audience around fortnight and learned
how to operate a
distribution platform on pc um in
android and now
as we've done with many things from the
unreal engine the epic online services
we open it up to all
other developers to use with their games
and are
trying to serve the industry and provide
a really interesting uh
alternative to the ecosystem but it's a
it's been funny there are a lot of pc
gamers who
just like to buy everything on steam and
so like kind of i'm seeing is like the
arch nemesis of these
hardcore pc gamers and it's it's funny
to be if you see in that way it's like
some sort of enemy to them all
especially considering your background
and um i mean the connection to unreal
and unreal tournament and
if anything you're still kind of the the
kind of one of their forefathers of
modern pc gaming and epic is that way
too so it's quite ironic that you might
be seen that way
for a lot of people maybe it's just the
old people that remember at this point
but
[Laughter]
well you know it takes a lot to change
an industry um i think the industry
you know the game industry still needs
to evolve and change further i think the
way that cross play was opened up in
this generation has been
a wonderful boon for games and it's
going to be even bigger and even better
in the next generation as it becomes
more pervasive across lots of games and
across publishers
um but you know these uh store model has
to change too it's
as i was saying about the engine and the
importance of developer productivity the
the hardest problem in the game business
for game developers
isn't even the creative and the
technical work that they have to do it's
uh
it's just the sheer cost of building
these products that
holds everybody back and it's a limiting
factor and so wherever you can ensure
that more of the money that consumers
spend
on games goes into the pockets of game
developers and not middlemen
including us as a middleman um that's a
great thing for
for the entire game business it it will
lead to better games
and better economics for everybody
obviously one of the things that
i and various other people who use epic
games or love is
free games um is that something you
intend to continue doing for the
foreseeable future is it sustainable
from a business side and for you and
your partners
i think someone calculated you've done
like put out like eight thousand dollars
worth of games or something like that
maybe other numbers wrong
but it's the economics of that process
are actually really amazing so
you know by doing a bulk deal with the
game developer where we buy a lot of
basically just pay them for the right to
release their game for free for one week
we've been able to get an amazing array
of games to gamers including getting
people to play games with types genres
they've never thought about playing
before
you're not going to go out and buy if
you're not into you know games like
satisfactory you're not gonna go out and
spend money to buy satisfactory but if
you get it for free you realize
it's an awesome game people people have
discovered a lot of great games that way
it's it's been a boon for game
developers most developers who launched
their games for free on the store found
that their sales on
steam and on console platforms actually
increased after they went free on epic
because of increased awareness um
and so so it's been a really positive
thing it's also it's brought a lot of
it's brought tens of millions of new
users into the epic games
ecosystem and that's been a wonderful
thing for the company fantastic well i
think sadly we're out of time but
tim kim thank you so much for spending
upwards of an hour talking to us and we
really appreciate it
um and we look forward to seeing more
from you guys and seeing what the future
holds for on real engine
it was awesome and honestly you did a
fantastic job interviewing it was really
good
thank you so much i appreciate it have a
great day guys thank you thank you
[Music]
right
do
so
looks live to me i'm alive
now can you hear me no it's probably a
thing this is the first time i've ever
had my mic
muted i don't want to make sure i want
to make sure everybody's
i know there's some gamestop people who
might be here it's a thing i do it's a
fun goof
it's a funny game it's a test for the
audience guess what they pass
so i just want to make sure everybody
can hear us and see us uh let's just go
around
the horn here make sure everybody can
hear everybody abby russell can they
hear you
hello one two three four whoo
[Music]
i'm here to play some games one two
three four i'm just doing what abby did
michael can i hear you what up what up
y'all
we're here to play some video games bro
and some more
can you hear me i hope they can because
otherwise i will be wasting my voice and
i hate doing that
don't waste that beautiful voice i'm
gonna put myself up a little bit
oh look at this nice graphic everybody
see this nice graphic
uh it is lovely it is very beautiful
um and i hope i got everybody's twitter
names right look i got twitter names you
can go follow people on twitter
there's donation amounts there we'll get
to all that in a second soon as
soon as i get confirmation from them
over in the the gamespot chat looking at
it
um and we'll just make sure everybody's
good i think
apparently young eric has done an all
caps yay
it's the only voice i trust uh okay
let's get started i think we just start
right
from here hello and welcome to everybody
i'm vinnie caravella
joined by abby russell and ben pak from
giant bomb
hello and then we've got some more and
michael
from game spots hi
and what are we doing here today what
are we doing here so
we have a we just kicked off day one of
play for all
a charity fundraising event which
originally was conceived by the team as
a part replacement for e3 because
apparently people will need e3 in some
regards
but also we wanted to do something
useful and helpful and
we decided that we wanted to raise money
for direct relief which is uh helping
out frontline healthcare workers
um in their fight against covert 19. in
the time since the world has
changed or parts of the world that you
know have always been there
are now surfacing and are more obvious
to people than ever
um and you know in light of that we
decided to also
raise money for black lives matter um if
you tuned in
earlier you'll notice that you would
have seen that we
placed our support over the next few
weeks while play for all is happening to
black lives matter
um and you can see the links in
the graphic there where you can go to
donate and but we're also encouraging
people to go out and
you know share amplifier voices that are
you know fighting the cause for
against social injustice and systemic
racism
but for our part we're going to try and
take the platform that we have
um in gaming and do as much as we can to
raise money for black lives matter and
covered relief
and the giant bomb team you guys our
friends uh
very graciously um uh accepted an
invitation to play games with us so
we're gonna goof off play games
um and hopefully do it for a good cause
yes
and while you were while you were
sending it up i just want to make a
quick shout out that i had the link
wrong
in the graphic and was able to change it
while you were doing that amazing intro
so thank you very much
michael you want to pick it up uh yeah i
just want to say one more thing before
we get started
is uh we appreciate your time and
attention especially for us
at gamespot and then being able to
extend to the giant bomb community
a lot of us are fans of giant bomb we're
friends with everyone there
and it's really nice when we get to get
together
to do something like this so uh it's
really important to us
here at gamespot and me and tomorrow who
are um
we're on earlier to speak on black lives
matter and why
we're doing this and why we're so
passionate about it all right
so i hope everyone can you know enjoy
what we're doing here
and i know times are tough i know money
is tight for a lot of us
but if you can give please support these
causes
they're very important to us they're
very important to everyone out there
so and continue to educate yourself
right after you get after you have a
blast on this stream you know we're
gonna have a good time afterwards like
after you support um with donations you
know continue
continue educating yourself continue
learning about what's happening in the
world
and take action when you can so
vinnie yeah i'll just i'll just add that
it's
um if this stuff makes you feel
really tense and anxious you are not
alone
i woke up this morning feeling like i
was gonna throw up so here we go
uh it is not a comfortable thing it is
not it's not supposed to be a
comfortable thing
it is a very uncomfortable thing uh and
i would just echo the facts that
or the sentiment of awareness and
uh amplifying voices and also
recognizing encouraging people to
recognize that this is a real problem
is is what you can do if you're
struggling also those links in the
bottom we will call out later
but for now should we start
let's go let's play some games so okay
the task was what's a board game we
could get together
play quickly with five people that we
could all learn
and play on a tabletop simulator this is
a game called deception it's got maybe a
subtitle which i'm not going to go into
i'm just going to call it deception
because i don't love the subtitle right
now it doesn't feel good saying
it so we're gonna play a game called
deception it is a mystery game
uh and uh abby and some more
and i have played uh some uh failed
versions of it on tabletop simulator and
we have gotten
uh we have gotten through some of them i
think we're going to be able to do this
it's going to be clunky it's going to be
fine
tabletop simulator i think is great at
what it does but also
it allows for a lot of weird stuff to
happen so
uh should we start who wants to just
flip the table first so i could reset it
perfectly
can we like flip it around to multiple
okay
[Music]
all right uh this is going to be
basically a
mystery ready so uh we'll kind of go
through here and start with the game we
won't
like a version of it we won't take super
seriously and then we'll gonna take it
very seriously
uh and so one of us is gonna be the
forensic
scientist in this right and i will join
that right now and later on we'll all
join this queue here okay
uh and you're gonna have to bear with us
as we all kind of learn this again
uh i'll just explain also if you're
watching the stream the colors on the
right hand side here will correspond to
where the players are
seated so uh everybody just say your
screen name because we didn't use our
real names which is maybe a problem now
i'm realizing is people are trying to
figure out who we are
uh i vinnie and mind cavity over here
i'm this color i'll assume it's either
red or brown being colorblind
okay thanks that's my favorite color all
right who's next
i'm abby russell um i know it's really
hard to decipher but that one's me
it's yellow i'm the little squirrel of
the knights outfit okay
i am tamor i like pink
okay uh next i i'm on purple i'm normal
human bartender jacket daytona
okay all right and then finally
i am brazy asian that is
a very old aim screen name that i carry
on into
my steam name so that's me i'm orange
and i'm glad thank you for sitting uh
seating the pink and the what all
is purple is that right next to each
other so i can tell by the contrast and
see them apart
otherwise i'd have a problem all right
so
i'm going to take all this off from what
i understand uh you want to use these
roles for
more than five players so i'm gonna undo
all of those
i'm gonna leave this on the default and
let's start the game we're playing
tabletop simulator this is in the steam
workshop
so uh it's not official but people man
they do a lot of work for these here we
go look at that everything's on the
board
so now everybody everybody's going to
have gotten a card here and now
the other players can't see your card
except for mine which says forensic
scientist right
everybody else is going to see question
marks right
so you're either going to have a card
that says
investigator or something like that or a
murderer
so you're going to want to keep that a
secret and don't tell anybody if i hover
over your card i can't see it yet either
and nobody else can see it
in front of you are going to be eight
cards the top
row top row is going to be a murder
weapon
the bottom row is kind of going to be a
murder accessory or a clue as far as i
understand it i will i should preface
this i have not played this for real in
real life we
practice playing this in our it's
everything about great in rehearsal so
it's going to be fun uh as it always
does uh so you have a top row is a
murder weapon bottom row is a murder
accessory so
i am the forensic scientist basically
think of me as kind of the dungeon
master for this if you've played dmd
before if you haven't it's not going to
help at all
the uh the other thing i should say is
pretty shortly i'm going to close
everybody's screen basically i'm going
to turn your screens off and i'm going
to
uh has anybody played werewolf before me
okay great all right uh it basically
it's gonna be uh put your head down
and then i'm gonna unblind the murderer
so if your card has a murderer on it
please don't drink the cardstock
it's gonna be so small already
i did look up yesterday to see if
there's any way to set it back to
default and i don't think there is
um so this is like my nightmare
explaining a game i'm glad i could live
it out live on the stream
um uh they should also have virtual cell
phones that everybody could just start
looking at while they explain the game
so the
other thing is uh oh this is this is my
nightmare
[Laughter]
uh so the other thing is i'm gonna make
everybody blood on the table and i'm
gonna unblend the murder i'm gonna ask
the murderer to point
with their hand to their card
so i'm gonna ask them point to a murder
weapon that's gonna be the top row
or point to uh i'll say a clue and
that's gonna be the bottom row okay and
i'm gonna take note of that
all right does everybody understand that
part
yeah yeah yes okay now
everybody i'll do it slowly and then
we'll we'll do that and then we'll start
the game
um i also want to say
there are ways to make permissions in
this game so you can't
make stuff big or whatever but i'm not
going to do that i'm trusting everybody
here
yeah we can trust each other we can
trust each other oh boy
okay here we go okay this is gonna this
is fine all right here we go
uh and then i think the other thing abby
is after that i grab a location
and then i draw a full range excuse me
draw four random tiles from the thing i
should have gotten water before this
i think so yes yes that's kind of what i
remember
okay i think each round we draw like a
new tile for like a new hint
let's get started this is gonna be it
everybody put your thinking caps on
uh the object of the game let's say
before we even get started the object of
the game
everybody has this little like uh little
very little badge
or giant badge that is next to their
thing
there are there are only three rounds in
the game
at any point if you feel like you know
who it or
or not even know who it is know what the
murder weapon is and the clue
right if you know it is uh one of these
cards or one of the clues both of them
you put your badge in the middle of the
table you will knock everything over but
that's fine we'll figure it out
put it in the middle of the table
especially if it's gigantic perfect yeah
i'll just put this back over here and
then um
you say what you want if you're wrong i
will say
you're wrong even if you have one of
them right i'm still going to say you're
wrong you have to get both of them right
and then you lose your badge and you
cannot make another guess
if everybody has lost their badge the
game is over or if three rounds expire
the game is over okay
so and everyone wants to get the killer
except for except for the killer so even
vinnie you want us to get the killer
right yes i'm on your team
so if if three out of four of you play
it and you're all the investigator and
the killer's the last one the killer can
just throw their thing in
and then um guess whatever well yeah
those
they could take a goof guess and be like
oh i guess the girl's wrong or um they
could just say i did it so let's start
we'll learn by example
everybody ready ready yeah yeah
yes okay and after we go through this
we'll take it slowly if you have
questions just ask it's a pretty
slow-paced game
um well it could be actually it kind of
moves pretty quickly after this but uh
we'll get started so the first thing to
indicate are we just putting our cursor
over our cards
yes please put one over the murder
weapon and one over the clue right
that's right i will
say i will say killer please uh
highlight a murder weapon
and then uh do that and i will just say
if i cannot if i'm not clear i will say
hey
don't definitely don't draw a circle
around it because in the chat it might
say that um
uh you know purple drew or whatever okay
let's give it a try if this one goofs up
we'll start it over okay
so first thing i'm gonna do uh first
thing i'm gonna do is um
blindfold everybody ready here we go yes
okay everyone is blindfolded yes
yes okay everyone is blindfolded yes
okay
now if if you uh abby uh everybody
everybody tomorrow michael everybody put
your hands well because everybody put
your hands down below the camera so
people watching cannot see
so you might be moving your mouse yeah
so if everybody wants to play along
um yeah ready so just just keep your
hands not on camera so that if you're
when i say that way they could if you're
the if you're an
yeah that's right so yeah okay uh so
when i say if you're the killer
if you're the killer please point to
um the the murder weapon
if you're the killer please point to
the murder weapon
okay okay everybody hold on because i'm
old i need to actually physically write
this down
because i forget this okay that's smart
uh and next
if you're the killer please point to a
clue
on the on the next row
okay okay
now i'm gonna
i'm gonna release i'm gonna release um
well hold on a second if you're the
if you are the killer please click
on uh the murder weapon again to
hopefully
release the highlight on it
okay and can you do the same thing if
you are the killer
could you please click on the clue again
to release the highlight also
uh nobody look at chat because i think
it'll say
what color was highlighted okay don't
try to win all right
i think you can shrink the chat so you
might that nobody looked there
okay i'm gonna uh unblind everybody now
okay i can see
i can sing okay great
okay okay all right so
i know i now know what the murder weapon
was and what and hopefully i'm getting
the rules right if i'm not
hey we'll all get through this right um
so now it's my
turn to pull pull one of these uh
location cards and i believe i get this
you can pick whichever one you want
right yeah for this
so let's see
what so i'm trying to guide you guys to
find
where this took place what would make
you pick the right
murder weapon here so let's see
[Music]
and i'm playing for real i'm not goofing
here this is serious
this is a really like kick as cause of
murder
all right uh it feels good to be in the
outdoors
by the way oh yeah we're blocking the
road though i hope no one drives over
here
nobody else should be out yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna pick this and now i have to
pick uh
uh this oh god oh there we go okay oh
yeah
okay a lot of information okay so now
now i take
this bullet and i get to pick um
what i think will lead you so the cause
of death was
oh interesting okay i'm gonna say it was
loss of blood
and i'm going to say the location was
a uh a common outdoor space
right now and this gigantic bullet which
i have to make a little smaller
uh the murder weapon belongs
uh i guess it was pretty easy to to it
was pretty easily accessible
um and then i'm gonna say
what was a sudden incident uh there was
a scream
and the victim's personality was
average they were of an average
absolutely nothing an average
personality
and uh um okay and then uh
i probably shouldn't be talking but
whatever uh
[Music]
the type of killer was
sexual just say it sexual we all know
uh i don't know
they were they were
amateur
all right so now uh let's start with
um timur you start and uh we'll go
around
in a circle here to ben and then abby
then to michael so you guys start
talking it out
okay and there's a clock we can start
here but i'll let's say i'm going to
give you guys about uh a five minutes
ish or until
it's kind of it peters out so uh
tomorrow you just kind of start deducing
and then kind of say
you know we'll go around in a circle
here and one more time we are trying to
figure out the murder weapon
and what are the blue cards it's like a
clue like hey i found this thing
at the scene or something okay so we
need to we need to
point out who we think is the murderer
the murder weapon and the clue you don't
even need to like
you know one will indicate the other so
you don't even need to say who they are
who the killer is but um
yeah yeah so tomorrow so the first thing
all right so the first
thing bullet really put down was lots of
blood but he kind of um then hard about
it
so it's kind of like via
it's not clearly loss of blood but it
means that there's a potential
couple of um options here so on
michael's side
um actually was it my actually let's
start from the side from abby's side
it's potentially
the meat hook that's a fishing hook you
can't lose blood with a fishing hook
on um on michael's side the ice skate
um is that michael yeah there's michael
the ice skate
on my side maybe
it's a great way to throw people off you
know if you were to if you were to
if you were to believe for some
erroneous reason that i'm the murderer
the throwing star and then on uh
average bartender jackie daytona
cleaver the cleaver
so those are the potential from that
first card the potential options
from my part i think abby raised a good
point saying the hook
the fishhook is probably not enough so
right now
i'm leaning towards either the ice skate
and
since i'm not the murderer the cleaver
on um average
bartender jackie daytona's side all
right
that's my thinking on the murder weapon
ben you want to pick up
uh from there um
yeah i don't really know what i can add
because that was such a good breakdown
well how about something for the clues i
mean either of these these things could
also be clues
i don't quite understand how the clue
relate like i don't
so any of these any of these hints could
either be pointing to the murder weapon
or be pointing to the clue like a loss
of blood
it could have been like a clue okay
or the location of the crime common
outdoor space
let's see um i'm looking at these clues
i'm maybe like an outdoor cafe for the
coffee
maybe i i don't know a lot of these
don't really
uh hammock maybe uh
over at abby i don't have a bleeding
thing
she doesn't really have a bleeding thing
i'm not the murderer
i don't know why i would cleaver if i
don't even know her
so and none of these come in outdoor
spaces
so can you can you stab someone with a
chicken bone of course you could stamp
something with anyone you try hard
enough i mean that's a lot of work and i
don't think an
average victim would be stabbed with the
chicken bone i also think that we if
it was a chicken bone vinnie would be
more likely to put in like accident
suffocation yeah like i'm looking at
these other ones and it's like
okay well severe injury probably rules
out like push down the stairs for abby
or yeah okay okay i think yeah ben are
you done with your pitch
yes okay so the ice skate i think
everything here is pointed to ice skate
we got loss of blood
common outdoor space a skating rink um
easily accessible
you can ice skate anywhere far more than
a throwing star and even a cleaver in a
lot of ways
i also think average what the [ __ ] is
more basic than ice skating
hmm i think if you were gonna ice gate
there would be a scream
there probably wouldn't be a lot of this
other stuff that's on the sudden
incident thing
killer amateur amateur ice skating i do
think the clue we maybe need more info
on i do think it's the most like basic
[ __ ] stuff
in this like bicycle sponge air
conditioning journal i'm i think
i'm like all in on michael i think it's
the ice skate
and i'm leaning towards like a sponge
all right michael
this is what now you have to do you do
the same thing you
who do you think is the what do you
think is the murder weapon
and what do you think might that might
the clue be
uh damn okay uh so i think this
uh murder was premeditated
uh if i'm looking at clues
wait what i'm saying are we missing a
bullet here
oh okay okay good okay yeah okay i'm
i'm going all in on tam right now okay
the push pin this is like
that board with that has like a bunch of
strings connected to each other you know
how many of those you need
to take
that's the clue so uh your weapon is the
throwing stars
so you're plotting i think you're you're
playing something
so right so you're saying that i use the
throwing star
in a common outdoor space that's easily
accessible
and shoe is not a common outdoor space
that's easily exposed
if you are playing and you are on foot
patrol throwing ninja stars you are
gonna get a call
the only way you throw a ninja slides if
you're on a roof and that is not a
common
easily accessible outdoor space
well i mean don't hey hey listen don't
let somebody push you around if you
you're you're you're
committing your convictions here okay
one thing i do have a question about
not to interrupt if you have something
you're about to say but for
pitching um like when we throw in our
badge to pitch
is that like a thing only one person can
do per turn what is the
incentive to doing it early or not just
waiting um
well you got to do it by round three so
uh let's just say you're
uh i don't know i don't know what the
actual incentive is to
not waiting but uh i know the glory i
don't know
like yeah i mean fair like or like or
it's like so obvious you're like i got
this oh
yeah i i i kind of feel like abby's on
the right track here
um i think michael him
my man's done some murder i don't trust
him you calling me average
no we're calling you basic where's my
badge
i don't know i saw no i saw this crime
it's over here it's in the bag
now we will never get it out of this bag
because i can't i can't move it
all right unless anybody wants to uh
throw in a badge uh for this one uh i'm
gonna move on to the next round
are we good to move on to round two a
lot of big badges a lot a lot of egos
over here on the
investigation for us i just want to make
sure it doesn't get lost together
how do you make the magic energy here uh
yeah a lot of big badge going on all
right it is plus and minus to uh to make
your
your badge uh everybody should know
these to make your things bigger or
smaller
all right so now it's not easy in real
life
now i get to pick a new card uh
let's say
i get to pick a new card and then i get
to put this down
and replace a card if i think
something's throwing you off or i think
you're getting it and let's move on to
help with the the murder weapon or the
clue i can now replace any one of these
with this new card which is not great
because it's just
a murderous personality which um
is not really gonna help on anything
here so let's get rid of this which i
feel like uh
is not helping at all and let's put this
in
and let's say
[Laughter]
[Music]
i would love to see this video please
well we'll catch you on the right track
here let's
uh i'm all about wholesome hentai but
don't talk about miku like that right
okay here's where i'm going
arrogant sounds like something a sponge
user would be entitled to clean
themselves
oh my god air conditioning
let's start this time ben let's start
with you we'll just uh then we'll go
around the
uh if you want or we could free
free-form it but um i think
there's a little more uh you guys could
play jazz if you want but just uh i'll
start with the structure and then feel
free to jump in so ben once you kick it
off with uh what's going on
sure i mean we're like a lot has been
said about michael and the ice skate
but i think abby threw off uh started
deflecting a little too hard there with
the hook thing
i definitely i've been fishing a few
times i've definitely caught a
finger a hook in my finger before
she's also being pretty arrogant i would
say right now about not being the
murderer
and have you ever played one of these
games with me before this is all i do
which just means it's the perfect clue
from vinnie to push us towards abby i'm
just saying i'm a little conflicted
right now i want to stay for the record
because this could be dangerous later on
i am describing the clues and not the
actual player
i want to make sure that this doesn't
get weird later on if we
have to describe a clue it is definitely
me
describing the clues involved and not
the people playing the game make sense
because you would have been perverted
clearly
let's be real um
maybe they did it out on a lake you know
i'm gonna keep it real like i'm gonna go
all in on this with you ben
so i think abby deflected hard now i
haven't played that many games with abby
so maybe that's
how you'd come at people in these types
of games i don't know but you know what
at this point that's all i can go off of
uh so fish hook
uh that's an amateur movie eric uh
arrogant because
you know listen rich people fish
i think that's i don't know if that's
true
easily accessible
easily accessible lake yeah common
outdoor space like out on the lake lots
of blood uh that's the only thing that's
gonna
kill but like yo um
uh i don't know i don't know what else
to go off okay
i'm ready to i'm ready to pitch so i
think
i think that michael saw any moment to
latch onto someone else which is why he
jumped on the abbey train so quick but i
think at the end of the day
ice skate is [ __ ] basic amateur and
makes you lose blood
also i think what's more arrogant than
having a journal and writing about
yourself
in journal that's where i'm at right now
i'm i'm going to go except for michael
pitch it in and then maybe we'll get it
or maybe
maybe um maybe it will
it'll just like knock it out so we know
it's not one of those okay
now for time i think that's a good idea
i will say that as someone who also
journals
i find your assessment of what
journalism is
quite upsetting but i'm willing to back
you on this
okay ben are you good go for it okay
michael
yo i am a badge i'm a police officer
i'm more than a badge and i would like
to say it is
michael ice skate and journal
yeah yeah yeah
that is that's impressive
[Music]
like how did you get journal though well
i mean like there's only four people
it was a guess it's also like what else
was arrogant but it was like
i don't know i took a swing
great purpose i'm ready for the next one
i'll be right back okay i'm gonna
try and reset everything as it falls to
the abyss um
i think i i don't know if there's a
better way to do this but
while while vinnie is doing that just
going to encourage people again to
use the links in our graphics to support
the two charities and two courses that
we are
playing games in aid of today and over
the next few weeks um play for all
um is supporting um covered relief and
you can see the 10 year old there and
also we are supporting black lives
matter
um please if you can donate if you can't
share um
yeah let's get let's do it
all right all right this time now we can
all join
in for the forensic scientist queue so
if you see that on the
your screen kind of near the middle on
the table you'll see join forensic
scientist q
you can push join and everybody will
queue up
um to get in there we'll wait for abby
to get back
so she can join us as well i don't know
if this is randomized um
but we'll find out i think um yeah i
think it's supposed to be that's what
casey said but
okay yeah we'll see yeah i'm gonna
i'll keep myself in there too just in uh
just in case
so all right well i'm just gonna say
um we will always know who the forensic
scientist is that's not a mystery it's
the who the murderer is
so uh if you are the forensic scientist
uh you will get a screen
on your right uh like a touch it's very
easy
it'll say blind everyone uh unblind or
blind murderer or unblind murderer it's
pretty self-explanatory
um so let's start the game and see what
happens
all right the worst part of someone
snitching on me is that
they're making some very good points and
i do not know what to say
okay vinny yes i am it's me i'm the guy
okay you are the forensic scientist so
yes the thing that you will want to do
is on the right hand side of your screen
you will see a thing that says blind
um blind everyone and you're going to
want to click that and then underneath
that will say
unblind murderer and then you're going
to want to click that
and then you're going to want to ask
whoever the murderer is to point
to a murder weapon and then you're going
to want to say
okay now point to a clue and then
uh at that point you're going to want to
either write them down or if you've got
a functioning memory unlike me you can
just remember it
um but you're you're going to want to
then lead people to like i tried to do
lead people towards those
and we can get to that after we come
back at the very end of that process
uh you're going to want to unblind
everyone
yeah okay also um usually it's good to
like before we get blindfolded not a
huge deal to like familiar
familiarize yourself with your cards and
also everyone else's car sure
everyone take a peek okay i'm looking
around the the deck here
got the old machete
[Music]
safe classic cartoon murder uh-huh oh
yeah
well while everyone while everyone's um
looking at each other's cards i'm just
going to quickly show a few donations
that we've had
yeah uh crystal channel very own crystal
chandler um donated um ryan peterson
andrew frangis i apologize if i'm saying
that wrong we've got a bunch of
anonymous donations as well a lot of
people are
um donating right now persia thank you
for donating dan
thrillman um great fox thank you for
donating
shane tynan um who else have we got
mello brown and then we've got a few
anonymous donations as well thank you so
much for donating everyone
yeah thanks everybody yeah good start
all right
abby has a card that's her weapon is
work
i uh yeah
i'm murdering all this right now are you
like someone's boss
everyone's blind okay now remember don't
give yourself away if the bed says
someone blind to the murderer
don't say okay everyone act natural i am
unblinding the murderer
murderer please point to a murder weapon
murder weapon has been acknowledged
please
point to a clue
clue has been acknowledged
okay now i unblind everyone
works for me okay everyone has been
unblinded
okay now we get those cards out somehow
okay so ben if you uh see these
location cards here you get to choose
which one you think
uh you want to use so you get to pick
which one and then you just grab it and
drag it onto the table
got it got it okay one second
what happened um
where is it okay
oh you make everything so small um
are you so small sorry i'm still take
your time no this is the part of the
just drag it onto the table yep yep put
it down next to the other card
got it okay and then a ben if you click
grab four scene tiles that'll give you
four yep perfect
now you just do the thing all right put
the little bullets where you want to try
and um
uh lead people okay cause of death i
believe
um let's go suffocation
hmm that could be hard of a crime
is a residence
safety victims hobbies
include the arts smells
in the air
we're gonna go human waste
okay the weather humid
okay this is a [ __ ] sauna and a half
and perceived by my sixth sense
um i'm thinking maybe
somewhere no that's not really human
waste is it
um oh i know exactly what this is
okay are we ready wait hold on i'm still
kind of processing wait what's this
familiarity
okay yeah okay blue blue okay
okay so now do i do i assign somebody to
go first
or you can pick somebody to kick it off
all right
uh michael since you were the murderer
last time why don't you kick off
human waste humid familiarity
uh goddamn
let's see uh who's this is that vinnie
um so i'm gonna roll with that sauna
thing uh
so i think that it's vinnie
uh familiarity human waste
i mean like look you sweat that's human
waste like yo that's
like sweat is nasty you're not wrong
that is a waste yeah
and what else are we gonna do for like
what else is gonna apply to human waste
right like yeah real like doo-doo
situations with anyone anything else out
here there are
[Music]
human humid buses with some waste on
them
yeah but are they um residential
yeah the sauna built into their house
yeah that's suffocation like
um you you turn the sauna up too high oh
boy i guess that's a cliche i breathe
in there uh so that's that's all i'm
gonna roll with as far as the clue goes
uh luggage because it's someone who came
over
to spend time at the house that has the
sauna
uh um well i don't wanna i don't wanna
it's my turn next i don't wanna yeah
let's just go around clockwise i don't
wanna throw anybody off this hot trail
this hot human waste
sauna trail uh but uh i don't have
i actually don't have a solid case to
make
uh i did think it was maybe safe at
first for residential suffocation
then the human waste thing kind of threw
me off uh
so i'm not exactly sure there
uh balloon could also be suffocation
because we have to keep popped balloons
away from people
uh like dogs and small children but
again that human waste
thing i don't know anybody pooping on a
balloon in the
toilet you never know one of my parties
[Laughter]
how about if you if you if you
suffocated if or like
as part of dying do you like vacate your
bowels
that could be an awesome okay that's uh
that's a that's a yeah
sure yes definitely so that definitely
changes my uh thinking here tam to uh a
bear trap or somebody just poop
themselves because they got bought
got a bear trap which i would honestly
or if or if i saw a scorpion so you uh
i would say a scorpion uh arsenic little
known thing about arsenic but i don't
think uh ben was going for this you do
does constrict your throat and that is
how you die
oh and that's better no no no
no no that's me oh sorry timur yeah so
yeah well i don't think
i don't think ben was going for that in
the suffocation i don't know ben you
knew that
arsenic constricts the throat and that
is how you suffocate and that's why i
thought maybe the sock with the arsenic
it's a stretch uh there's also a flute
which maybe he was out of breath
uh so i guess i'll just lead with
arsenic and
the so are you are you saying that i
poisoned some person and as they
suffocated therefore i was playing the
flute
uh listen uh maybe you put the arsenic
on the flute
hmm oh that's actually a um
because he is one right damn the ball's
in your court
and some accusations have been thrown
your way what do you have to say for
yourself so
i i think arsenic honor flute is
wrong and wild i think vinnie i think
vinnie is
vinnie is currently uh a murder leader
in my eyes um sauna i think sauna
works for um suffocation um
residence as michael heim said um this
one is attached to someone's house this
person's house
and then what is underneath this the
arts
not sure about that one but like there
is a violin on
infinity's side um human waste i think
like
the suffocation when whoever whoever
discovered this person
uh-huh by the time they were discovered
like this person had pooped themselves
the
the dead their bodies still stuck on
human waste so when
when they were discovered there was the
the smell of uh waste in the air
i would the eyes it was my turn i think
it was already humid as well so that
contributes like if you're in a sauna
and it's already humid you're it's hot
as hell already you're going in there
um you're just making the chances of you
suffocating to death
in a sauna even more likely and then
familiarity
i think as a heim says like you would go
to someone
who you knew um like you wouldn't go to
your mates house to
use this honor unless they were super
comfortable
i mean this is i think i think i think
they like might be staying over
that's what the luggage was for hear me
out hear me out what
work all right check check this check
this
like we need to think on another level
we need to open our third eye like i'm
ready i haven't even pitched yet
yeah we should we should
okay my pitch is i want to throw my
badge in now so actually if you do have
some kind of strategy
slam it all right i'm throwing it in
saunas are attached to the [ __ ] it's
a sauna and you know who loves
the arts people play the [ __ ] violin
sauna violin vinnie did it
uh that is correct yeah
uh nancy drew again
yo all right i am i am not doing any
crimes around abby ever
again i am all right maybe you're
wrong well no tomorrow how to fly
why is what i kind of realized i had
like five clues pointing towards the
murder weapon and only one
actual clue um all right i'd like to
take a little bit of credit for that
um interesting uh comment in the youtube
chat from david lewis says why don't you
blow off the arsenic when you
started playing the flute is that how it
would work vinny
uh we're gonna we're gonna throw it to
our arsenic expert okay i i would like
to
just admit here that i know nothing
about arsenic and made up that entire
thing about suffocation and constricting
the throat oh
uh throw you off the case also don't
look at the chat what are you guys doing
out there i'm not
what do you do i would never absolutely
i would hey that's another mystery
i'm not looking i'm not i'm not looking
at a chat in between games i'm doing it
when i need to read the
uh when i need to read the clues
no no i would never suggest that but
nobody look at chat unless you're the
murderer then you can look at the chat
so we can watch
everybody's head turn uh when they look
at the chat all right i'm gonna hit i'm
gonna hit reset
game uh and hopefully
hopefully that takes care of this mess
that's on the table but hopefully it
then just will make
that that is no longer a bullet that's a
nuclear warhead
okay all right all right all right
everybody hands up so
uh because we've had trouble with the
reset game thing before
here we go i think it worked oh okay
almost
so close didn't fit in the bag
but it automatically knocked me out of
the queue which it should which it shows
because everybody gets a chance at it
all right so i'm gonna hit start game
again
and here we go if anybody has questions
just uh everybody kind of gets it now
right
uh yeah okay here we go hitting start
game
oh i am a forensic scientist okay
[Laughter]
the trickiest bit but that that means i
i'm i'm a game master right
that's right yeah so if you have any
questions just ask but uh otherwise
there's just the lightning mcqueen in my
clues
okay the murderer
so my first step is to here look can we
look at the cards first yeah i want to
look at like oh yeah
that seems legal
everyone peruse these cards
and let me know when you're done oh wow
look at this yeah that attack dog is
serious
said uh business check people's cards as
a sign i can check people's cards as the
scientists
you can yeah everybody can see the cards
um
so you can uh hit alt to go over
anybody's card you cannot see their
murderer or investigator card
but you can alt to see everything else
uh but you will find out soon once
everybody's blindfolded
what the uh what the role is okay
what is dirty water i know i saw that
one
what's the difference between dirty
water and i guess leading people between
dirty water and amoeba might be a tough
one
uh oh some of these are good oh no
a bone wave oven have you played yakuza
um that is microphone
all right i am good i am ready i'm ready
yeah i'm ready y'all good all right damn
you good
yeah i'm good okay so my first step is
to blind everyone
correct okay blinding everybody
what happened okay
now the next step is to unblind the
murderer correct
so okay i'ma unblind the murderer
and don't show your reaction
okay now the murderer has to select
a weapon and a clue correct please do
that
i was about to say let me know when
you're done
please don't let me know when you're
done okay
um now i can unblind everybody
are you are you sure that you know who
the murderer is now and you know and
you're
okay so unblind everybody
yay you see everything okay i have abby
you okay
no i didn't pick a clue oh i'm so sorry
all right all right all right all right
going back to reset game
all right that was the practice too the
thing vinnie did real quick which i
wasn't ready for
is he just kind of like when he was
picking stuff he like did little circles
over it and then i was like okay i got
the first one and then he did little
circles over the clue
and i think that's the best way to like
[ __ ] i'm so i'm so sorry happy
okay okay all right i'm gonna hit reset
game but uh then
uh michael you should just throw
yourself back into the queue
when i do that so add yourself back in
um and i don't know uh well
i don't know if it's random but um we
can try yeah let's all leave so that
you're at the top of the queue
hopefully i don't [ __ ] this up again uh
and then [ __ ] it up abby leave the
queue oh i have to leave the queue and
we'll rejoin just so he's at the top of
the oh okay okay
yeah and then okay yeah rejoin if you
haven't uh done it okay great so i'll
start the game hopefully it's not random
and it's just as
cute but here we go so now the murderer
will be different but uh that's good
so let's really oh will it let's start
the game again
perfect well i'm forensic scientist okay
oh all right i got these cards are these
cards
got these cards i miss my lightning
mcqueen
i know i was all i had a plan and i was
all ready
yeah i don't know what blood released is
actually is on uh on your side then
um does that mean is that loss of blood
let's see is that like is that like
bloodletting
is what i don't know it's bloodletting
that's like when you
like be intentionally intentionally
letting someone bleed out instead of
like stabbing them and then
oh and then it just happened to be yeah
i like the idea of alcohol but it's beer
that's my drink
you have to drink like 60 beers look it
was a slow one
you were an enabler yeah it's i like the
six pack of
legitimately just budweiser like they
don't even go out of their way
it's just bud
[Laughter]
so yeah same as lightning mcqueen i
think i
am oh i have a sword and that looks like
um
that's very much like um no that's not
really a witcher sword i don't know i'm
disappointed now
look at my leather shoes though they
don't match
oh yeah yeah gross murderer unsettling
um okay i'm ready cool
let's uh let me try not to [ __ ] this one
up but i'm blinding everyone
all right i'm going to unblind the
murderer and please make no indication
as to who you are
all right do your thing
all right
okay um so now
i am i've done this correctly and i have
realized uh what the murderer is trying
to communicate to me
uh so now i must unblind everyone
correct
yeah okay unblind everybody
sick uh and let me jot this down before
i forget yeah
i wonder if there's there's a note field
here i'm gonna write something
no i think that might be a public note
okay um because there's like a no thing
in the bottom right but that might be
public
okay now now my job is to pull these
cards and
set down some uh that's right
so the first thing would be uh the
location card so you get to pick which
one of these
you think is the best location card
towards the top of the table here so you
um
you can kind of roll up there and then
be like oh i want this one
and then you'll grab the scene tiles all
right
uh while while uh uh michael does that
tim you want to uh shout out
yeah so um show um the links i can do
that
um ten year old.com
gs hyphen blm that is our um link to
support black lives matter
um and then you also see um ten year old
dot com
four slash gs play for all and we're
raising money for
um corporate relief efforts as well as
black lives matter
um following the tragic events of the
last couple days and
the um the effort to
you know um support the ongoing uh
uh kind of effort to make sure that
social injustices and systemic racism
are brought to the forefront and
addressed and
um kind of discussed openly so that it
can be addressed um
we are providing our support in doing
that we're raising money for black lives
matter so if you can
please donate if you can't share the
stream
share share information about black
lives matter you'll find lots of
resources
um on on the on twitter a bunch of
people are doing amazing
work sharing that stuff but yeah
if you can please do donate all the
money is going directly to those two
causes we're not taking any of it we're
not involved in that we're just directly
supporting those um
courses okay michael you
you only take one of the locations sorry
i didn't want to interrupt you more but
yeah you only you only take one location
michael
this one is multi-dimensional i'm so
sorry yeah you just hit that button
right here and then take it let's
grab four and lay them out on the table
so there's a little button that says
grab four
tiles or you can grab them from the bag
that's fun that's another way to do it
no that's fine
and then just pull them out of the bag
yeah just pull four of them out of the
bag okay
yep like uh there's i will i will rotate
this around
okay
[Laughter]
that works for me i think i gotta be a
little quicker on the thing okay
and there we go and then we'll do that
oh
all that training paying off there we go
okay now mike
now michael you'll want to use the uh
yeah now you want to do your thing oh i
feel so calm
no no you michael you should have seen
us trying to doing this
last week trying to figure out how to do
this thing it was
a comedy of errors as we're like
knocking stuff off the table and
how do you rotate how do you zoom thank
you for lending me your wisdom
and we may proceed on investigating this
crime
uh okay so you don't want to say too
much as the forensic investigator you
kind of just want to lay the
the pieces down without giving too much
away so that uh
like we can follow the breadcrumb trail
okay
cool and find who the murderer is who's
not me
i don't know that's something a murderer
would say
dormitory silence
oh loss of blood is man this blood
released
really just shouting out of me i don't
know i don't know
uh i mean also there's an axe yeah and a
sword uh yeah uh there's also
well i don't know tim i feel big fan
betrayal
graffiti uh i think um
are we pitching no i'm just gonna
spit ball in here thinking out loud
physically
physically okay physically
days am i am i uh am i the base
discovered
wow now now that i have put down these
bullets am i
like this is final i can't move them
around it or anything
like that yes but we're not like playing
super strict if you were like oh
oops uh but i would say
once we start discussing we should we
should probably not move them around
because you'll have a chance michael
you'll have a chance in the next round
if if you feel like um
we're being led astray to swap one of
these cards out
and replace it so so michael pick
someone to kind of kick things off and
then we'll go around the table
the virtual table all right i want to
hear
what abby has to say because he has been
on point
yeah i'm just i just want to hear okay
so
loss of blood and dormitory i'm already
feeling like sword and chalk
because like sword is also like a good
sense of betrayal
and a good physical thing as far as
silence and daze
i don't know but the chalk also just
feels like the
dormitory oh that although you'd
probably do classroom if it was chalk
um but looking at other dormitory items
maybe a flyer maybe graffiti
could be like a flyer and blood released
i think oh there's also surgery whoa
took days is also a weird thing i don't
know all i have is sword and chalk
so i'm gonna stick to it sense of
betrayal the sword seems like a real
sense of betrayal
that's kind of where i'm where my head
space is at
i'm a little thrown by like silence and
days
um can i pick it up next go go for a
minute okay i'm going to say
um not seeing a lot of loss of blood
onto more so i'm going to come back
today except for the sharpened fan
which uh it could be i mean a sharpened
fan that's very
um is that molina or katana ben who's
that
um um
so i'm gonna axe is definitely a
loss of blood that's a big one but like
i feel like the ambient noise wherever
an axe might be
might not be quiet i don't know if it'd
be silence or like a dormitory doesn't
necessarily feel like an axe but it
could be in the fire
or the fire thing but that also seems a
little
a little tough um i feel like the
dormitory is probably like a clue thing
more than a weapon
these weapons are like school related
and also seeing the sharpened fan i
actually changed mine i think it's
sharpened fan and lunch box
oh interesting a sharpened fan could be
pretty cool
dormitory yeah like yeah you know like
it's like school
right some kind of dormitory i mean yeah
i don't know
uh it was noticed because of the
physicality or physically is that what
were
noticed because physically i don't
really know what that means
i don't know what that means because
physic
me off huh something something
physically
was noticed but it took days
so it could be okay i think interesting
uh there's also this blood released
which is uh
which is definitely something but all of
these clues
make me think that it would be like loud
like you have a flyer
that's going to be at a loud place
dentures are always funny people would
be laughing puppets
seems quiet
okay so i'm gonna go i'm gonna probably
just kind of lean towards the
the axe and abby side but i need more
clues only only
only because silence
only because she doesn't know it yet
that means she's probably the murderer
who would be jumping on anybody and like
doubling down if it was me
all right that's right so like if abby
weren't the murderer she would know
exactly who it is
so so that's that's where i am all right
tam
uh so the ones that stick out to me so i
have concocted a story in my mind
let's see how this goes loss of blood so
my
my the person i'm building this around
is abby
um acts acts lots of blood obvious
doesn't need to be explained dormitory
so the person who died was someone was
in the doratory
another fellow student um ambient noise
silent i think this took place at a time
where
people weren't in the dormitory so like
spring spring or something like that or
summer where
traditionally students would go home but
in this situation two people have stuck
around
um sense of betrayal so
that person clearly knew the other
person so for the acts
to be killed that's where like a sense
of betrayal is what
led to them being axed um
physically i feel like the reason it was
noticed is because like
um maybe it's like a pool of blood and
uh became visible
outside of the actual dormitory
maybe and then it took days for it to be
found because there's no one else in the
dormitory everyone's gone
including like the you know the staff so
that my story i think it's abby with the
x
all right that makes no sense uh oh that
sounds very defensive
then uh yeah i don't have a lot to say
that's already been said i think
i'm between vinnie and abby
[Music]
because they just moved in the only
thing that trips me up on abby's is the
axe makes a lot of sense but the clue
i'm still trying to figure out maybe
it's video or maybe it's
just i think it's the video camera like
that's where that
might have been come like i'd be happy
with filming this person
secretly okay i like that that's gonna
be well
don't forget abby it's the ambient noise
which i guess would be like what's i
don't know was the
noise in the room quiet but we could do
another let's do another round i'm not
ready to throw it in
yeah i'm not ready either but i'm
leaning i think we got to keep an eye on
this sharpened fan and lunch box that is
a sense of betrayal
that is probably silent it's also maybe
in a dorm or
i'm still leaning towards like sword and
chalk because i think chalk is more
more dorm than lunchbox probably okay
but
also it's not classic murderer
everywhere and you're not the murderer
who jumped on you guys are
randomly jumping on me or whatever uh
all right you guys did it together
you're both uh this team is falling
apart so the
uh the next thing michael would be
select one card take the the bullet off
the card and then
um you can replace that card by grabbing
another one from the bag
so you get the card the other card first
and then you then you take it off then
you get rid of this blue
okay so this is a new card i'll just put
that down there
it is backwards mirrored
okay let me see if there's uh
[Music]
okay thanks dad
hoping you guys investigate it's fine
okay uh so i'm going to choose which
card to take out
preferably the one that has not helped
that's right that's exactly right
okay i am getting rid of this one
this don't make no sense and i am
putting this one here
the scene okay i don't think this is
okay so the scene state of this
state uh state of the scene okay so
uh water stain
tidy until oh okay i think
i'm visualizing this scene in my head a
certain way
that is becoming very hard to
communicate through these cards
and i'm very like attached to the way
i'm seeing this and i'm sure none of
y'all are seeing it
you just have to invite us into your
mind that's right that's right open the
door we'll walk through and we'll find
it don't worry mm-hmm
mine palace where's that from i should
know
uh hannibal and sherlock's been in a lot
of foreign
tidy and untouched
yes okay that's what i'm going with
even untouched this is all
coming together in my mind wow days to
find it
um who won first last time abby you went
first right
yeah yeah okay go again no i'll go
murderer okay no okay betty
i don't trust you or tomorrow y'all are
[ __ ]
working together let me just i'll start
your honor i'll start with the defense
here of
all right clearly none of these things
on my side are we all know the effects
of arsenic suffocation not
going to happen
let's look at the real facts here uh
we've got an axe which is clearly the
loss of blood
we've got uh we've got a dormitory where
any number a cupcake
who hasn't gotten a cupcake for a friend
who hasn't snuck
uh some weed or smoke in the ashtray
who hasn't done some videotaping with
their old 4k camcorder in the
dormitories
and who have you can only choose one
clue who hasn't fallen in love any of
these could really be
uh we got the silence of uh silence of a
video camera
i don't know that doesn't make sense
we've got a sense of betrayal
filmed you were filming me oh my gosh uh
uh it's a tidy uh an untouched
video camera and then this is somehow
having the opposite effect i think it's
good
[Music]
like would the days be i had time to put
up graffiti
like
i think i think tidy and graffiti like
don't don't make sense to me
um i'm trying to just look at other i
don't know
tidy and untouched this is a very clean
ash tray
it's a very clean ash tray blue vinny
it's also just you pick one
so the rest are just not there at all oh
yeah oh i know
i know it is you have to match one one
uh one uh
listen i've murdered before i know how
this works
he'll do it again yeah uh i'm you know
listen i'm starting to lean towards
action ashtray that's where i'm leaning
but i'm not ready to throw in granted we
only have one more round
so um i i rest my case
does anyone else want to go um before i
i am
i am less convinced about abby now but
because the uh [ __ ] benny here okay
i'll pick a pitch i'll make a pitch
for vinnie
[Laughter]
oh boy okay i am making a picture
for sword and chalk going with my gut
again
because i think tidy and untouched i
don't think it would be a lunch box
because i want i think a lunch box is
like food and you're there
and like i don't think it's that sharp
and fans still feels like betrayal
and still feels like loss of blood but i
think sword can still be betrayal
still be loss of blood i think it's a
sword and chalk
i think it is i think
all right oh my god
[Music]
i'm split kind of 50 50 on this i'm
calling it
oh
[Music]
oh no and it's slammed on the table oh
my god
before i before i make this pitch i was
uh before i accused i want to say abby
that was a good
pitch but okay you're if you're voting
for me get ready to
lose your badge the joke the chalk i
think michael hym is smart enough to
if he if there was chalk involved he
would put it on classroom instead of
dortmund
you don't say if any of them are right
you have to if they're both right you
say yes and if
either one of them are wrong you'd say
no just say no that's it
okay uh no
throw that bag
so uh tam can no longer make a guess he
can still participate in the discussion
and once we're out of badges the the
game is or the
the murderer gets away um i'm ready uh
ben i don't know about you but i'm ready
to see another round
yeah that was gonna be my guess too so
i'll see you another round i'm telling
you it's the [ __ ] sword the chalk is
maybe cardboard box
because the dorm is a good point but i'm
going to i think oh hey tater i think
it's the sword
and the chalk okay okay that's what i'm
rooting for
i'm looking at these clues and uh okay
well let me pull out another one more
i'm ready for another we can only do one
more
let's see what we got duration of the
crime
distance don't help
i like that unclear is an option
what am i an investigator
does that mean this is helpful this
could be helpful
yeah if there's a virus or like surgery
you know like that's helpful or beer
alcohol
well if it was surgery then it'd be like
quick hours
versus let's get rid of this one
okay okay yep okay which one was that
sense of betrayal okay
that was my fan theory yeah you know
sort betrayal and sword with carrying a
lot of heat
uh for this duration of the crime oh
here we go here we go
um gradual and prolonged are
almost synonymous
those three are like okay uh let's just
i'm gonna go with prolongs
whoa this is blue oh no this one just
set my apple cart oh no well because the
sword is not that prolonged
[Music]
i can't say anything further have been
vinnie i'm just gonna pitch you
something here yeah pitch me
there have been arrows in video like
could it
be like somebody was filming somebody in
their dorm getting shot by arrows
that's very incriminating ben i think
you're the murderer i'm almost ready to
drop my badge on it because like i
honestly i think i think
pam was right on with the chalk thing i
think he would have put classroom
yeah um yeah so i but like maybe it's
cardboard box and sword
i'm gonna do it i'm ready okay i'm
calling it i'm putting it
right before you do this we got two
shots of this right
uh well only only one only does but one
person's a murderer so all right
i'm doing it abby no dude go for minnie
we only have two guesses it's not my
official guess is arrows
and video camera negative
okay it's my [ __ ] turn
[Music]
it all comes down oh man if you're not
the murderer do
um do the fan and and
lunch
[Laughter]
i might not be the murderer but i'm
killing it okay so let's go
oh my god i like that huh uh
[Music]
let's see i whoops the badges flew away
let's see
i got rid of it so all right so
everybody at the table can um
can help me figure this out so you can't
make a guess this is like family
this is like yeah this is like family
feud style now like you go down the line
i think you're the killer but okay
okay let's let's imagine that let's
imagine that i wore it for a second
because i'm not going to
be really messed up if he was milking
this
you're gonna be so mad let's let's let's
imagine that i'm not the murderer
let's play let's play like that for a
little bit but okay uh let's see abby
who would you pick if uh if it weren't
me
i would pick the sharpened fan and the
lunch box
okay let's not bring fantastic maybe
maybe a flyer and blood release but i
feel like ben would be stupid to pick
blood released
when we had talked about it a bunch
before the murdering happens
i feel like the duration of the crime is
not gonna be
a with prolonged with a fan a sharpened
fan that's gonna be a pretty quick crime
right
like you're gonna cut someone and then
you gotta be done right that's what
the loss of blood and the prolonged i'm
thinking maybe blood released over here
because
uh that's going to be like a bleeding
we're going to have loss of blood
and it's going to be a prolonged thing
and it might be silent
in the because it might be like an
operating room or something like that
right so uh it could be there
uh i'm also thinking surgery that's a
very tidy place
um the problem is blood release and
surgery are very similar
um also if it was surgery wouldn't it be
like accident
or like illness disease
it could be but that would also be loss
of blood right so that's a tough one
that's a tough one um we've also got
this water bot we need so
the time until discovery could be days
which i'm thinking maybe
blood released like it was just kind of
like you know the blood out right bled
out over days it's kind of uh
over days that happens pretty quick i
think well
i don't know depends how big the cut is
if we had that fish hook again
who knows um so
i i'm thinking maybe here so abby i'm
kind of i'm moving away from all yours
here because i don't think i think we're
having blood released on the microwave
i think the axe would be a pretty quick
uh duration
of the crime arrow as well my instinct
was way wrong so i guess
it's on you maybe i i'm still voting
sharp and faint in lunchbox
i think dormitory is so specific the
only thing we really need here is this
uh
clue and that's going to be a tougher
tougher one to figure out so
i feel like with the the dentures
i feel like flyer would be more likely
because it's a dorm
yeah but would it be ambient would that
be silence
a flyer it's hanging on a wall well i'm
assuming the flyer you'd probably be
like
you know something going but there are
no
things here all right damn what do you
think you're pretty silent for a killer
cam i'm trying to figure it out i'm
still convinced of you
i think it's a sharpened fan in the
lunchbox i still think it's i still
think it's
maybe two but somebody's somebody's just
trying to figure out what the
combination is
[Music]
[Music]
no i wasn't on my a game this time i
didn't get an easy win
for us but none of these clues make
sense to me
okay i think i feel like i got i got to
make a difference
arrow and rose rose
using an
no but it's gone but it's still factored
in at one point but not forgotten yeah
i think it's i don't know okay i gotta
make a guess i'm throwing in
any our own rows do it all right do it
don't do me it's not me don't do me
you're wasting it
okay all right
all right here we go i don't know the
clue
lunchbox lunchbox is the only other dorm
thing i don't know
i don't know i'm throwing in i'm saying
loss blood released
for ben and i'm saying
same fire
why would it be dentures um it's gotta
be fire right
it wouldn't be water bottle because that
would be water stain would be an easy
one to put there
um disorderly flyer i don't know
[Music]
i still think it's abby flyer
no oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
or would it make perfect sense because
it'd be so obvious
here's here's here's my
like listen like if you look at the rest
of the locations that i could have chose
from like
my classroom
i was thinking like okay art students um
you know they're
they're they're puppets they're doing a
play
um [ __ ] uh i don't know
it's all right all right should we do uh
i mean i i think you're within your eyes
to flip the table
that's right table wait if you flip the
tape okay i just gotta make sure i get
that recently
[Music]
why why man i'm sorry for excusing
everyone
but then yeah it was great literally for
like 90
of that every other person was being
accused
yo ben was chilling too like i was like
wow this is the easiest
murder that he's got anyone's getting
away with in this game also
i'm like damn there's some [ __ ] that
i got stuck
lots of blood bleeding out like okay
that's easy but like how do i
communicate puppet that kind of pervert
puts a puppet in their dorm
a murderer do we want to do another one
of these we've probably got what like a
half hour left we could do another one
of these we could try i've got two other
games
uh we can try if we want uh but not
everybody has been the forensic
scientist and i already did the murder
we could do this again i'm having fun
i'll leave it up to uh
let's try one more and then maybe if we
have um if we have time at the end after
this one
uh we can try it the other ones are
quick but uh let's uh code names
no not code names it's uh spy fall and
uh cockroach poker which are pretty easy
to learn but
um they're also pretty quick as well so
uh if you want to be forensic scientist
put your name in if you haven't been
already i've done it yet
yeah so joining me hasn't done
uh and then i think it's just abby
you'll just be it i don't think it's
actually random so
uh yeah and then hit start game i can't
you gotta do it okay you know i was
ready because i'm the murderer here we
go
okay well um i'm just gonna hang out
while y'all look at cards i'm looking at
cards
let me know when i should blind people
follow the ice skate again remember that
huh remember the ice skate i got the ice
cream oh yeah yeah
an old favorite snail tire iron
i want dirty water to win
you always say that oh yeah oh wow this
arm
i do not like the photoshop cutout of
this
whoever's hand is on it though just
touching that bicep with this tattoo
yeah there's another one right
oh rat cotton got a rat with a knife no
that's like marshmallows
locked room okay nice sculpture
troll what is a troll there goes
for planting wow
um pants locked room that is
sadistic uh are you ready to be blinded
i am ready i'm gonna get my game face on
make it uh
okay not obvious that i'm blinding
everyone
everyone is blinded yes yes yes
i'm unblinding the murderer
okay murder is unblinded
and now i am seeing the cards they are
pointing at
i have their murder weapon i'm writing
it down i almost said it out loud
okay and i'm ready for the clue
okay i have both
they are written down i am now blinding
the murderer
and now i am unblinding everyone
okay is everyone blinded can you see yes
okay
great all right um okay okay okay now i
get to do my cards
so cause sam you want to do another uh
shout out rickshaw yeah um yes
uh we are raising money in aid of uh
black lives matter
and also covet 19 healthcare worker
relief efforts uh
along with direct relief um we've had a
few
donations uh anonymous ones so thank you
for those
um please do head over to those links if
you can
donate um if you can't please share and
spread the word that we are doing this
you can see a couple links um
you'll find them on if you're watching
on youtube you'll see them there
just send those about um and also try
and educate yourself a bit if you can
um you know there's plenty of um
resources available
that will give you um guidance on what
to retweet what to post about
go to the black lives matter website and
you'll find a lot of that there so
please do
um raise awareness and help us fight
social injustice and systemic racism
and you um gamespot will be doing this
for it's uh it's a month
is that right yeah we're going until
uh early july i believe it is 12 and
we're gonna have programming
every day um you can go onto our website
and
go to uh gamespot.com you'll see a
schedule there
um right on the front page so you can
see exactly what's coming up
um and we'll be here every day um
until the end of mid july so plenty
plenty too for you to enjoy
and we're hoping to raise loads of money
thank you guys uh and uh in addition
to that um there's also
and this is happening we'll all be
in this one together the e3 stuff or not
e3 will
will also be happening around the the
let's call it around the edges of this
around the edges of the the charity
stuff
um there'll be some e3 coverage as well
for sure all right
um let's find a murderer
okay so i put my pieces down
this is for the first round cause of
death
suffocation location of crime the
bedroom
victims hobbies fashion type of killer
a sexual deviant finally state of the
scene
tiny and untouched victim's identity
mail
you do the rest
uh right out the gate the combination of
oh well location of the crime kind of
throws this off but
i thought i see suffocation and really
the only
thing that is pointing out oh well belt
actually oh yeah that throws a mention
everything
i'm looking at belt i see sexual deviant
i'm thinking like some weird
belt sex stuff um tidy untouched you
know they were in the throes of passion
probably
uh so everything was like ready for that
they kind of had snacks and stuff ready
to go
actually i just realized you're talking
about me
the victim's hobby being fashion maybe
thinks
makes me think tattoo could be the clue
um and male that looks like a a
gaia arm i don't know i don't know if
that's kind of where it falls apart
but i am leaning right now initially
towards belt tattoo
i was going to say the same thing belt
tattoo like uh
male like you know that that dude was
wilin
he was doing some [ __ ] with the belt so
that's you know i'm not gonna kink shame
i'm not gonna king chain but in this
case it got someone killed
and his partner uh or their partner was
probably
into i don't know fashion if it's
a designer belt maybe you know uh that
that's a thing
definitely bedroom suffocation it's easy
this is a slam dunk bro
round one one take throw it in
oh i i i'll put my badge i'll put my
badge yeah are you sorry
earlier
[Music]
locked room which is who's this this
guy's been
um locked room thinking of
hunger not suffocation yeah i guess so
bedroom i might i don't know maybe a
bedroom is what's like pushing me
towards locked room as well
like it doesn't necessarily say the
suffocation the death came from
uh the suffocation didn't happen you
know
the suffocation happened by the room
being locked it could be in in there
um right i don't even have a locked room
card i don't know what you're talking
about
like the bedroom here i'm thinking like
suffocation
fashion i'm not sure how that would work
i mean like cotton is all i can come up
with for fashion
it could be someone like works in
fashion if you oh the hobby is fashioned
that means could be working
with cotton to make stuff
[Laughter]
no this
it kind of sticks out to me because the
locked room but i can't think of
anything else for
like what's going okay mine comes
michael i mean i'm not sure what to do
okay this toy car right here just like
like the budweiser one
i think disney's gonna have a problem
with this so that's a sexual deviant car
if i've ever seen one
uh disney you're gonna have to take it
up with tabletops
no don't they're fine they'll find they
take it up with someone else
they'll get they'll get this fine
product shut down yeah
[Music]
when we're ready i'm down to uh put my
badge as tribute
i'm right here do you want to speak
first or i want to say
okay i am putting i'm putting it down
how do i make it bigger can i make it
big
plus hover over it hit plus
sorry wow i'm just causing all kinds of
trouble
i am okay i think it's it's it's pretty
this one's pretty easy
and we're all in agreement that it is
belt and tattoo
sorry tam you you've wasted that
no that is not true that's not that's
not it
oh that's not it okay okay all right
yeah i'm ready i'm ready for the next
round next clue okay
grabbing a tile oh that's working um
that was pretty
cool okay i am going to
what don't do it
okay hold on i got it i got it
okay okay okay just a sec okay
so this one evidence left behind
okay okay i don't understand
what you're saying yeah actually
evidence left behind
behind well this this is going to throw
the case wide open
there can only be one thing left behind
peter come here buddy um i'm gonna do
so this would relate to the clue right
this is the the like a perfect thing to
just unlock that clue yeah okay i'll do
synthetic
oh no yeah
who's got pants oh fashion
and fashion and synthetic we got rid of
fashion but
all right but like it's still there
hymn's got pants
i got i haven't got pants you don't have
pants but what's the suffocation here
vinnie's gone i wear a little tight
pants that's definitely
isn't that nice what kind of suffocation
you get suffocated
bedroom suffocation synthetic
for this person
okay tangled depends i'm i'm gonna
i'm making a guess okay okay you're not
gonna talk through it or anything
no
to prove that i'm not the murderer
because why would the murderer make a
guess like this
without talking through it that is
huh right airtight here we go
i think
it is
the belt and the yoga mat
yes you guys are so close so quick
that's so cool
yes all right i'm resetting game
[Music]
all right uh here we go what's that
helpful um
well it's sometimes you know it's
interesting it's the things you don't
pick so like you didn't pick creative or
anything so
that's right it's the clues you don't
pick all right uh so we looked through
and then uh oh i got a gaming card
what's up gamers oh no video game
[Music]
an console ps4 that's a good one there
buddy
oh a leather streak killed him with the
fan at all i hope you're i'll be the
killer
oh dirty hands look at that there's some
guilty dirty hands
that's for gamers too right is it oops
oh yeah look at that thing old-ass phone
okay interesting starvation wow just
says starvation
makes it easier right what if a clue
just came up starvation
suffocation severe injury
signature what idiot signs the crime
scene uh you know somebody like one of
those like
vanity um
[Applause]
[Music]
um all right everybody ready
yes okay i'm gonna blind everyone
okay is everyone blind i can't
i'm blind can't see [ __ ]
i'm going to it's it's not letting me
click on blind murderer
all right let me try again okay
murderer pick your murder weapon
okay i have the murder weapon now can
you pick your clue
okay i'm going to
unblind everyone
okay is everyone good yes yes yes
okay now i need to select one of these
cards for location correct
let me just double check
oh you could stack them oh
your q
are you also a little smaller i have to
only assume this is what forensic
scientists do while they're waiting for
uh touch everything
oh boy i'll re-enlarge this one a little
bit
maybe he's making a vote apparently he's
voting
so i've got one location now i'm just
grabbing 14 pounds there
uh yeah you can do that or grab four
tiles it just puts them down okay
all right interesting dragon's off my
badge ben
flicking it two
i feel like we've lost one
oh it's stacked nice stack there's a way
to flip it is it alt
f there it is okay
all right
oh hey buddy
okay suffocation classroom work weekday
oh man assume and work
a teacher oh i think i see some stuff
[Music]
in a bruise
[Music]
and the weather was hot um all right
there we go so weekday work f5
suffocation in a classroom
in progress work crime was on the
weekday
tracing was a bruise tracer scene was a
bruise
um
hi peter he's climbing all over
computers
oh peter you want me to sushi
peter yeah we used almost named sushi
when we got him oh wow oh
yeah tim do you want to pick someone to
start
i'm going to pick tata i mean
[Laughter]
i mean i'll go i'll be tater surrogate
okay
okay suffocation i think the thing
that most seems like suffocation i want
to say
buried alive i think suffocation
is the best fit for that one but
[ __ ] classroom yeah really throws you
for a loop huh
yeah and like work well work makes me
think
work work death suffocate under
i mean if you're going to be worked to
death suffocation is probably the best
thing unless you do like illness or
disease work is a disease after all
so actually i'm going to say you're
suffocating under your work
you work in a classroom um
weekday these are all work things bruce
i don't [ __ ] know um wait how does it
leave a bruise
if they are worked to death
food ingredients what's um
anesthetic what is that
anesthetic is uh like uh you know the
thing you get for not feeling pain
okay sure yes well hot
hot i mean
uh hot
cotton quilt is hot but
what what's a weekday
this is not helpful at all none of these
make sense
okay maybe i shouldn't go first i mean
right now i'm leaning towards work
and then i don't know what the other one
might be maybe
food or hanger for bruise
i'm just going to say since i'm being
accused abby has a leather strap
and clock i think that you could kill
suffocate someone with a leather strap
it'll lead bruising
there's a clock in the classroom um and
if you're working you're always looking
at the clock wondering when five o'clock
is going to roll around
um michael what was your battle i got
i was gonna jump off of what abby was
saying
and so work work out look i want at
least
one case for work to be the cause of
death so there's so much stuff pointing
to work here
blues i'm gonna look at there's a
listen listen i'm gonna get there i'll
get there all right so work
and anesthetic watch so suffocation
classroom work classroom work it's a
teacher
on a weekday because after school is
stressed out
uh and it was a hot day because um most
likely classrooms don't have air
conditioners because they probably work
at a poor public school
uh like i went to and then brews so you
take the anesthetic they were like oh my
god i feel so much pain i'm gonna
uh i'm gonna take all these anesthetics
they oh why are they feeling pain
because they're they're underpaid
teacher bro okay it's the opioid
crisis i guess yeah so you're like they
was just downing the
the painkillers and it caused
internal bruising i don't know i don't
know what that means
i don't know like okay so there was
something happening with their blood on
the inside and they ended up bruising
because they took too many of those
things
um and they suffocated that's it
i think that's a way longer walk than
leather strap and clock but
you know follow your heart i know we can
go with like leather strap and clock
first and then if that doesn't work then
we can uh we can
get you votes wait where's my passion
so i'm thinking okay there's only one
thing throwing me off here
well there's actually two things
throwing me off i mean so there's the
shipping container
which could be like somebody at work got
caught in a shipping container
um like on the dock kind of thing but
the classroom is a tough one so like
maybe the clock
was the classroom thing because it looks
like a school clock
but then there's no i'm going to be
honest ben made a good argument for my
leather strap and clock
but my argument against that is if i
were playing this game i would have
picked something much more interesting
because i want to be the murderer so bad
and cutlery seems like a cool weapon and
broom seems fun
yeah but you like winning yeah it's true
but i don't know i think it's still work
there's so much stuff pointing to work i
think it has to be work
and then i think all of the weird [ __ ]
is like pointing to some clue that we're
just not really getting
because also if you look at like the
scene with bruce it's like it's all
confusing
why clowns unless you have suffocated
somebody with a leather sure
but if you suffocate someone there
wouldn't be a blood stain there wouldn't
be bodily fluid
there probably wouldn't be a scar which
is the only reason why i'm like
what other options are there for that
card uh so maybe that's like one of the
cases in which
you know it's you gotta go with like the
least uh ridiculous
way for the next question yeah i think
i'm ready to wait like i'm kind of with
you it's this classroom thing that
like i can't find a thing to match that
that's well so i'm i'm ready to
i'm ready for next clue okay why is this
there
i'm so convinced it's work though it's
gotta be
yeah pick the square above it rather
than the background it could be that
yeah just the drag from the
from the bag i got one for you okay
of course can you grab it now oh i hope
the corpse is twisted
i just noticed that all these cards are
written with
those chinese characters or kanji
oh that's right yeah um
okay i need to think about which one i
need to get rid of here
ben i don't trust you
[Laughter]
as long as you everyone doesn't waste
their guess on me we'll be okay
okay what are you getting rid of what
did you do
work okay so we must have been wrong
with ben's work thing
i'll admit it oh
definitely still warm oh yeah
oh hey we crossed the uh three thousand
dollar uh mark for
whoa thank you so much
remember you can donate using the
tinyurl links below we're raising money
for covert relief efforts and black
lives matter
both important causes the gamespot team
and
i met the giant bomb team as well and
our company as a whole so
please donate generously if you can't to
spread the word
and try and educate yourself about the
issues the systemic racism and social
injustice that black people face
and do your best
uh still warm tam is what you've picked
yes okay okay okay i'm going back to
buried alive because still warm
feels very much like this person was
buried alive
i don't know i think that's all
indicating like they're alive as the
murder's happening
which makes me think buried alive i also
think looking at buried alive and
looking at location of crime
i don't know why he wouldn't have chosen
playground um but
the rest of them dormitory cafeteria
elevator public toilet would not fit
a classroom doesn't really [ __ ]
either though
[Music]
is like they're practicing cursive it's
only the class yeah i mean my thing is
like classroom could also be like yo-yo
kids like the classroom could not be the
buried alive it could be the
the stuff around right like the right so
the clock
the bruise also throws me off the bread
maybe they're in cooking school
they got bread buried alive
but none the thing is aside from maybe
dirty hands
none of these things are suffocation
like none of
michael's or suffocation yeah
but i think you know the more i thought
about it she would have chosen something
more extravagant i think i think
i think that's true i love fun and i
wish i was the murderer
uh there's also packing tape
i robbed abby of her being a murderer i
get the barry alive and i'm 50 yoyo and
i'm about to pull the trigger on
signature because i'm thinking kids
in the cla roos though maybe yo-yo
yo-yo is bruised like kid you get hit i
think it's yo-yo and buried alive
are you is that for you actually do you
want to i can do it yeah i can do it
wait hold on
before you do this i just want to say um
matt hawking has donated
10 and said if i die please let abby
investigate my mother
buried alive yo yo
no
[Music]
i think it's this i don't know what the
classroom is though
all right we got one more clue right yes
yeah we
yeah we should wait for the other clue
all right yeah i'll take this last clue
yes
[Music]
about a little bit um okay so i think
the classroom thing is definitely the
thing that's throwing me off from
anybody else's and i only see
if i were doing it i would say it could
be broom or clock
because i don't see any murder weapons
that would be classroom
except like the pia now we would have
video game in the classroom
um michael doesn't really have anything
i forgot that i was a potential suspect
oh have you now um yeah
i feel like dirty hands is the closest
of like a strangulation thing
well packing type is quilting is
hot kids kids do have dirty hands like
in a classroom
that's true but like not me but that's
like the murder weapon
you know i am definitely one of them for
the clue uh another clue
before i answer so okay okay hold on i
have another pitch i have another page
before we move on
that maybe could be michael the
classroom is still a little like i don't
know
but like dirty hands and the quilt you
could
suffocate someone using a quilt with
dirty hands and it would be hot
i feel like you would have picked up
some toilet for dirty hands
that's true very topical huh yeah yeah
you're right
the classroom's really well but also why
i think it's yo-yo but
also the still warm could go towards
abby's quilt thing like maybe the quilt
was very cozy
those are very cozy i know that's why i
think it's like quilt
um all right i want another clue yeah
inspired by spider-man
i just want to say the clues i've had to
the to the things that were picked are
awful
they are utter shite yeah wait oh
wait are
[Laughter]
oh
you did an innocent impression of me and
misconstrued
in an interesting or is it construed who
knows
wait okay well let's see the next
question
um murder inspired by what do you mean
oh okay i see what you mean um
okay i'm gonna get rid of wow none is a
choice that is
very uh helpful if you pick none
god this is difficult
oh man passion i
want to hold on hold on okay no no not
passion
okay well we got rid of hot which is
still a clue okay
right it doesn't mean that it
invalidates it it means that it is maybe
just not as important
that maybe we were just like thrown off
so wait none
all right so let's see what it was
signature and buried alive so it wasn't
inspired by television
it wasn't inspired by copycat passion
i feel like suffocation i'm 50 50
between
barry alive signature and dirty hands
quilt i think it's quilt like i feel
like
maybe like hey move away from that
what's it called murphy's law
the the yeah
and this leather strap is still sitting
there me okay but
let me just make a pitch about dirty
hands really quick so with dirty hands
often what other of these death things
would work with that i guess maybe
severe injury
but like or maybe illness or disease or
maybe accident okay i guess there are
other options that are maybe better than
suffocation for dirty hands
never mind carry on ben go and accuse me
you're wrong but do it
keep in mind i lost my badge nothing
here has gotten me
off of the scent of leather strap clock
i'm just saying like none of these new
clues have pointed me away from that
um inspired by none doesn't really help
i um
i'm trying to meta game abby like last
time when she was
not the murderer she really wasn't
everyone
said [ __ ] in the
was sitting there wild his dirty hands
and his cotton quilt and his [ __ ]
baguette saying nothing
all right abby also was quick to vote
which is a sus
for me i kind of think i could go in on
the
i could baguettes are hot
i guess you have during the weekday
baguettes in the class you have during
the day
that's true i do like it
bruce also might work with dirty hands
i think i'm the only one who voted right
yeah okay yeah but this is the last
round
i have to follow my gut i'm voting oh
yeah yeah
okay i am voting
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the fact that you're voting next
probably a good sign for us
dirty hands baguette dirty hands
baguette i
i feel like ben if it were abby that
would have been it
like that was what i was on for the at
least for the classroom thing okay let
me make another pitch for dirty hands
baguette
okay dirty hands could be bruised
dirty hands could be classroom for sure
murdered not inspired by anything
i think and then baguette i think you'd
stuff it in the mouth
maybe it's buried alive in signature but
what i'm saying is vinnie
has got a vote for this for michael and
then michael's going to vote for vinnie
so it's either one of them right
it's true i don't know maybe [ __ ] ben
but i don't think it's been based on
this [ __ ]
yeah i don't find anything on board
either i think
i think it's based on classroom
maybe signature but um michael you vote
you've got to save your signature maybe
it's buried alive and
you go first boy so we rule it out oh
wait no don't go first because then
maybe
it's the murderer wait what michael's a
murderer okay
okay look listen i'm just gonna say this
like if if you all vote for me
it's gonna be wrong you're so
that's that's my case okay just straight
up michael i think it's bad getting
three hands
wait who is okay so abby you already
used your vote yeah
i'm sitting out so is someone gonna take
her up on that uh investigation it's
only you two
it's just oh really yeah yeah yeah uh
well i'm not gonna vote for me so
uh and also i'm not the killer so if you
vote for vinnie will you vote for barry
to live and signature i guess you can
choose whatever you want but
that's what i was thinking i'm gonna go
i'm gonna you know abby's
does not miss or whatever
[Laughter]
she uh hits him a lot more than she
misses so i'm gonna go without any
further reason i'm gonna go with barry
alive
and signature
no i told you i told you
[Music]
i vote for dirty hands and quilt
no of course it wasn't it's good it was
me
it was me what was it it was literally
it was ladder why is
[Music]
my mind you get more my mind can get
suffocation from ladder by placing the
come on in
on the ladder on the neck oh it close
the ladder on someone oh no
no oh
[Music]
it was it was the janitor in the
classroom he was
doing his he was doing he was at work
trying to fix an air conditioner on a
hot day
there was a kid
as soon as when he picked those two
cards i was like i'm screwed okay
there's nothing i can do here
it's the same thing with ben how do you
do a ladder and it goes
superior injury he fell off the person
fell off
accident was one of the choices yes wow
how do you make yo-yo work with that how
do you make yo-yo work with that
classroom
[Music]
um all right i think that's gonna do it
we broken the game completely listen hey
hey hey hey i wanted it to be an
entertaining end
and i think we're going entertaining in
there that's right that's right
we have played tabletop simulator uh uh
tim and michael thank you so much for
inviting us on to the stream
why don't you do one more uh one more
shout out here and tell me
where they can go and what they can
expect for the rest of the week and
catch everything
for sure uh gamespot is doing play for
all for the rest of the month and
into july we are raising money for black
lives matter
and for covet relief um you'll see on
the screen two links that you can follow
to
get um your donations in if you can if
you can't please
share the links and um spread the word
that we're trying to do this
where we're putting our best effort into
empowering the people who are fighting
social injustice and systemic racism
um i think everyone it might be tricky
right now to try and
you know play games and enjoy it but
we're hoping that by
doing that on a platform where we can
push people towards those issues we can
make that easier for you and hopefully
we can benefit
um people who are facing these issues on
a daily basis
yeah and if i could say a few things as
well is that
um you know we really appreciate
everyone giving us the time and
attention as we do these streams and we
really appreciate the donations
to help those uh in need uh whether it's
for black lives matter or coca-19 but in
the case of black lives matter i think
it's really important that we understand
why we're pushing for this because
we can't have all lives matter until
black lives matter
and black lives matter is a organized
movement
that we can get behind and i think that
you know tomorrow and i us we spoke this
morning to kick off the stream and i
think it's important to recognize
uh who we are and what we can do beyond
donations because this is not a thing
where we donate
and the problems solve we keep fighting
this problem all right so
um tamar and i are we're non-black
people of color
and i think it's really important that
we take it into our our communities that
we keep communicating this
and we fight alongside black voices and
black people and that we listen to them
we listen to them and we fight with them
and i think that's important for
everyone to recognize i will go back
uh to you know my asian american friends
and let them know like yo this is
this is our fight too we need to fight
this as well and i think that
you know white people need to do the
same uh
in communicating that as well everyone
can do the same and
communicating why this is a problem and
how we can
perpetuate a better world for everyone
else and
especially uh black people who are
facing the brunt of the injustices and
the police brutality that we're seeing
around the world so
i thank you all for donations and
joining the cause
and keep fighting keep going keep
educating
yep i think that's right thank you guys
so much
and uh if you want to see a schedule of
all the streaming that's going on they
can go to gamespot.com and go check that
out
uh you'll be streaming to twitch if
you're watching this on the giant bomb
channel you can get stuff over at
twitch.tv uh slash gamespot yeah
yep that's correct and youtube twitter
and facebook as well to stream pretty
much everywhere thanks everybody for
watching and donating like has been said
here a lot of people
uh trying for a lot of good causes to
raise money
a lot of people suffering out there not
only uh within our communities all over
the world
um especially with the covet stuff just
compounding uh the fractures that are
already there
within our society and our government
and everything else out there
so if you're at home hope you're staying
safe uh
and i hope everybody is doing well and
if you could donate donate thank you to
more
thank you michael thank you abby thank
you ben i'm gonna hand this off back to
uh
whatever happens after this after i
after i fade this down
uh on giantbombs you're on giantbomb.com
stick around
uh it will not be uh uh the play for all
stuff right now i don't know what's next
on the schedule benner abby do you know
what is next
i do not know we went over it this
morning and that feels like a million
years ago
[Music]
and tomorrow michael what is up next for
uh for a game spot
uh that's that's our scheduling for
today um we're going to be continuing to
publish stuff on the website news
stories editorials that kind of stuff
and everything is we're doing from now
until the end of um
the uh the play for all campaign is
focused on that we just published our
uh interview with tim sweeney and kim
library of epic games so if you missed
that it's available on youtube and on
site now
and so it's worth checking that out yeah
yeah and now i want to thank uh
everybody who came in again abby ben
michael uh tamar
for letting me have a fun time during
some very serious times uh i think it
was uh
it was good to have a a bit of a laugh
with some friends
uh and again uh thanks everybody for
donating i'm gonna fade it to black
uh everybody good yup okay
here we go thanks everybody bye
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
two
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
you